ओके सो आई थिंक वी आर लाइव नाउ अ हम लाइव
आ चुके हैं फाइनली अ जस्ट लेट मी नो गाइस
इफ आई एम ऑडिबल एंड विजिबल एक बार मुझे
बता दीजिए इफ आई एम ऑडिबल एंड विजिबल तो
आवाज जा रही है आप
सबको दिखाई दे रहा हूं मैं आपको अच्छे से
तो एक बार मुझे बता दीजिए एंड ऑडियो
क्लियर है यह भी बता दीजिए तो जल्दी बता
दीजिए फटाफट ताकि हम स्टार्ट करते हैं एंड
आने देते हैं सभी लोगों को एक बार जवाइन
करने देते हैं हेलो हेलो गुड इवनिंग गुड
इवनिंग टू एवरी बडी कैसे हैं आप लोग क्या
हाल चाल है सर बाय डूइंग लाइव बग बाउंट
कोर्स वी लर्न मेनी थिंग्स फ्रॉम
बांग्लादेश गट टू नो अ
लॉट ओके ट्स ग्रेट वी आर ग्लैड दैट यू
गाइस आर लर्निंग एक्चुअल थिंग्स थ्रू दिस
सीरीज
राइट सर डीसीसीआई से अटेंड कर रहा हूं भाई
डीसीसीआई की क्लास अटेंड कर लो यार
लाइव क्लास है
वो ठीक है चलिए तो मैं एक बार खुद से चेक
चेक आउट कर लेता हूं यहां
पे आई थिंक ऑडियो वीडियो सब कुछ सही है तो
जल्दी से आ जाओ लाइक ठोकते हुए
फिर सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं जल्दी से
सभी लोग जवाइन कर लेंगे फटाफट जवाइन
करेंगे जल्दी से ओके आई थिंक एवरीथिंग इज
गुड सो अभी थोड़ी देर और वेट करते हैं एंड
सबको जवाइन करने देते
हैं
चलिए वॉइस कम आ रही है आई डोंट थिंक सो कि
वॉइस आपको कम आएगी बट मैं फिर भी एक बार
चेक कर लेता हूं इफ वॉइस इ और हाई तो चलिए
अभी वॉइस आपको आई थिंक सही आएगी मेरे
ख्याल से नाउ द वॉइस शुड बी शुड बी हाई तो
अी मुझ बता दीजिए एक बार वॉइस अब आपको
क्लियर आ रही है मतलब साउंड ओके है नाउ टू
हाई कम कर लो यार टू हाई है तो कम कर लो
मैं 95 पे कर देता हूं
[संगीत]
इसको ओके सो मैंने 95 प कर दिया है मैं
इसको थोड़ा सा नीचे कर देता हूं राइट ठीक
है अभी वॉइस सही है सही है बिल्कुल सही है
ठीक
है ओके
ग्रेट तो यहां भी 50 देयर इज नॉट 50 पीपल
राइट नाउ अभी 50 लोग तो नहीं हुए है तो
थोड़ा वेट कर लेंगे हम उनके आने का इंतजार
करेंगे एंड उनको बुलाएंगे तब हम स्टार्ट
करेंगे तो लेट्स वेट गाइस सो यहां पर मैं
एक बार यह ओपन करके डिसेबल करके अन ओपन
करता हूं यहां
पे
ओके या इट्स ओके इट्स टोटली फाइन संतोष
टोटली फाइन ठीक है गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल ऑफ यू
गुड इवनिंग एवरीबॉडी आए हैं यहां पे अभी
ऑलमोस्ट 40 लोग एंड लाइक्स ओनली 24 दिस इज
नॉट फेयर एट ऑल तो लाइक ठोकते जाइए एंड
सिर्फ 40 लोग हैं अभी बाकी लोग कहां है
यार जल्दी आ जाओ जल्दी आ जाओ जल्दी जाके
ग्रुप में बताओ सबको कि लाइव स्टार्ट हो
चुकी है एंड टू जॉइन द लाइव
राइट चलिए सेशन आज का बहुत शानदार होने
वाला है आज के सेशन में दो चीजें हम कवर
करेंगे एक जो जेडटी टोकन का हमारा एक
पार्ट बचा था ब्रूट फोर्स का पार्ट उसको
कवर करेंगे एंड ये ब्रूट फोर्सिंग आप किसी
भी पर्टिकुलर जेडब्ल्यू टोकन पे कर सकते
हैं दूसरा हम लाइव हंटिंग करेंगे लाइव
टोकेंस फाइंड करने की कोशिश करेंगे
अलग-अलग
अप्रोचेबल डिफरेंट
अप्रोचेबिलिटी ट्रेनिंग का एक ही मोटिव
होता है कि आपका माइंडसेट जो है उसको
डेवलप करना टू डेवलप योर माइंडसेट राइट जब
आप उस माइंडसेट को डेवलप कर लेंगे ना तो
फिर यू डोंट नीड एनीबडी लिटरली यू डोंट
नीड एनीबडी यू कैन डू ऑन योर ओन ठीक है
चलिए आई एम गुड स यूज एंड कांग्रेचुलेशन स
यूज फॉर फाइंडिंग वैलिड वनबिल एंड गेटिंग
पेड तो यहां पे मैं आपको एक चीज दिखा देता
हूं अ हां फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल यहां यह मेरी
प्रोफाइल है आप आके यहां पे इस यूर पे आके
एंड यहां पे आप मुझे फॉलो कर सकते हैं साथ
में यह जो है हमारी कंपनी की प्रोफाइल है
डिफ्रॉक साइबर सिक्योरिटी राइट सो यू हैव
टू जस्ट कम हियर एंड यू हैव टू जस्ट फॉलो
दिस पेज कि आप एनी काइंड ऑफ कोई भी आपको
अपडेट मिलेगी कंपनी से रिगार्डिंग
स्टार्टअप के रिगार्डिंग किस तरीके से हम
कंपनी को धीरे-धीरे स्केल करते जा रहे हैं
किस तरीके से क्या-क्या हम चीजें कर रहे
हैं कंपनी में वो सारी अपडेट्स आपको यहां
मिलेगी डिफर साइबर सिक्योरिटी लिंकन पेज
के ऊपर दूसरी बात यह है कि आप में से काफी
लोग जो स्टूडेंट्स हैं लर्नर्स हैं वो
बाउंटीज या बग्स फाइंड कर लेते हैं वैलिड
तो वह हमें टैग करते हैं
सो वन ऑफ आवर अ लर्नर अ मैं इनका पोस्ट भी
आपको दिखा देता हूं अ दैट नेम इज़ अ हिज
नेम इज़ सयस राइट तो सयस को आप में से
काफी लोग जानते होंगे एंड ही जज बीन विथ
अस फ्रॉम वेरी लॉन्ग टाइम एंड इन्होंने
काफी डेडिकेशन मेहनत से छह से ठ महीने तक
यह लगातार हंट कर रहे थे एंड अब जाके इनको
इनकी पहली बाउंट मिली है एंड हैकर ऑन
प्लेटफॉर्म के तरफ से ऑलमोस्ट
₹2000000 का बाउंट इनको लगा है एंड इट्स
रियली रियली ग्रेट अचीवमेंट मेरे
अकॉर्डिंग एंड ऐसा बंदा जिसको मैं काफी
टाइम से देख रहा हूं इसको बार-बार
डुप्लीकेट्स या इंफॉर्मेशन क्लोज होना
बार-बार चीजें बट फिर भी लगातार उसमें लगे
रहना इज द बिगेस्ट थिंग जब आप वन एबिलिटी
फाइंड करते हैं तो एक टारगेट के ऊपर लगे
रहना इज द बिगेस्ट थिंग तो इन्होंने यहां
पे पोस्ट भी डाला है यहां पे इन्होंने
मुझे भी मेंशन करा है डे फोनिक्स को भी
मेंशन करा है एक अच्छा खासा वॉर्डिंग लिखा
है एंड यहां पे इनको बाउंट मिली है सो वी
हैव आल्सो फीचर्ड हिम ऑन आवर पेज तो हमने
इनके पोस्ट को बेसिकली रीपोस्ट किया था
एंड यहां पर जब आप पेज पोस्ट पर जाएंगे तो
यू कैन सी हियर दैट वी हैव कांग्रेचुलेशन
सयस फॉर देर अचीवमेंट राइट सो इट्स अ वेरी
ह्यूज थिंग इट्स वेरी ग्रेट थिंग फॉर एनी
काइंड ऑफ एनी टीचर कि उनका जो कोई
स्टूडेंट होता है लर्नर होता है जब वो कुछ
अचीव करते हैं तो उनसे ज्यादा खुशी मिलती
है लिटरली मुझे फील होता है सो यू ऑल कैन
कांग्रेचुलेशन स यूज राइट तो आप भी
कांग्रेचुलेशन कर सकते हैं चैट में सयस को
ही इज आल्सो
हियर सो यू शुड बी लाइक अ आप एक दूसरे को
जो हौसला बुलंद करते हैं ना वो आपको करना
चाहिए
राइट ओके चलिए तो यहां पे अभी हां एक और
चीज है मैं अ बहुत सारे मेरे जो
स्टूडेंट्स हैं जो बग्स फाइंड कर लेते हैं
राइट अब मैं आपको एक चीज और बता देता हूं
आप लोगों को आप लोगों को वो तरीका बता
देता हूं जिस तरीके से अ आप उस चीज को गिव
गिव अप कर सकते हैं दे सकते हैं आप उस चीज
को जो भी आप चाहते हैं उस तरीके से आप कर
सकते हैं एग्जीक्यूट बहुत सारे जो मेरे
व्यूवर्स हैं जो लर्नर्स हैं बग बाउंट
सीरीज के जो बग्स फाइंड कर लेते हैं वो
क्या दो-तीन बातें मैसेज करते हैं कि
मैंने बग फाइंड किया है सर आपकी वजह से सर
बग बाउंट सीरीज की वजह से काफी कुछ सीखा
ये चीज किया सर सर हमें बाउंट मिली है या
फलाना डिकाना मैं सर आपको ट्रीट देना
चाहता हूं अब ट्रीट मैं कैसे लूं मुझे ये
नहीं समझ में आता है मेरे लिए ट्रीट क्या
होती है कि आपको बाउंट मिल गई या आपको
रिवर्ड मिल गया स्वैग मिल गया वैलिड बग
आपने इनफैक्ट सिर्फ वैलिड बग ही फाइंड कर
लिया दैट इज गिफ्ट फॉर मी दैट इज अ ट्रीट
फॉर मी फिर भी कई लोगों के मैसेज आते हैं
कि सर प्लीज बताइए मेल पे करते हैं प्लीज
लिन पे मैसेज करते हैं कि हमें ट्रीट क्या
देना है तो अगर आप में से किसी को ट्रीट
देना हो कभी फ्यूचर में कभी कुछ ऐसा तो
मैं आपको एक यूनिवर्सल तरीका बता देता हूं
ठीक है एकदम मस्त क्योंकि आई एम जस्ट अ
फूड लवर तो आप ट्रीट कैसे दे सकते हैं
amazononline.in ज गिव इट अ ट्रीट
तो अब आपको अगर आप ये वीडियो देख रहे हैं
तो आप जस्ट य के फॉलो कर सकते हैं अगर
आपको देना है ट्रीट इफ यू हैव रिसीवड द
बाउंट याद रखिएगा
बाउंटीज जाएगा ज्यादा बेटर होगा आपके पास
पैसे आ रहे हैं तभी ठीक है अदर वाइज कोई
दिक्कत नहीं अगर आपको रिवॉर्ड या स्वग हॉल
ऑफ फेम मिला है यू डोंट नीड टू प्रोवाइड
दैट राइट तो ये बाउंट वाले लोगों के लिए
है तो यहां पे ईमेल आईडी डाल दीजिएगा
फ्रॉम नेम आप अपना नेम डाल दीजिएगा जो भी
आपका नाम होगा अ वो नाम आप अपना डालिए और
कुछ अगर मैसेज डालना चाहते हैं मैसेज
डालिए क्वांटिटी अपना रख लीजिए उसके बाद
सिंपली आप इसको बाय करके जब आप बाय कर
लेंगे इसको तो यह डायरेक्टली मेरे ईमेल
आईडी पर डिलीवर हो जाएगी n13 gmail.com प
ट्स इट तो आपको मैंने ये तरीका बता दिया
यूनिवर्सल तरीका जिसको भी करना है भाई
आराम से जोमट का गिफ्ट कार्ड भेज देने का
राइट वहां पे आप अपन क्या करेंगे उसको
अप्लाई मारेंगे और मस्त फूड लवर वाली जो
फीलिंग है जो वो है वो जगाए ठीक है तो य
आपके ऊपर है
सर नॉट एप्लीकेबल होता है टेंशन नहीं लेना
यार हो जाएगा नॉट एप्लीकेबल है तो कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है अब मैं आपको सयस का ही बता
देता हूं ना ही ज बीन हंटिंग फॉर वेरी
लॉन्ग टाइम एंड बारबार सयस तुम खुद ही बता
दो इनको अगर यू आर प्रेजेंट हियर राइट कि
आपके कितने सारे बक्स इनफॉर्मेटिव या नॉट
एप्लीकेबल या डुप्लीकेट क्लोज हुए उसके
अकॉर्डिंग यू कैन जस्ट कीप ऑन
ट्राइट्रियातुम
ग्रेट ग्रेट यस रुद्र रुद्र आपने भी फाइंड
किया है
दैट्ची पे एक्सेसेस फाइंड किया था
इन्होंने तो इन्होंने भी टैग किया था एंड
ऐसे जो चीजें होती हैं ये लाइक लिटरली
बहुत ज्यादा इनकरेज करती है हमें और
कंटेंट अच्छा देने का एंड अंदर से खुशी
होती है वो खुशी जो है एक्सप्लेन नहीं कि
जा सकती तो आप यहां देख सकते हैं बग
रिपोर्टेड यहां पे जो है इन्होंने किया
हुआ था डीप सीक अ के ऊपर में बेसिकली
डोमेन था चैट डीप सीक एंड सीडीएन के ऊपर
जो यह वल्नरेबल थी यह वहां पे फिच कर रहे
थे एंड इट्स अ वेरी ह्यूज थिंग लाइक इट्स
अ गुड थिंग जब आप कोई भी वनबिल रिपोर्ट
करते हैं हमें तो मजा आता है
तो यू ऑल हैव अ यू ऑल कैन डू दिस थिंग
राइट अब स्टार्ट करते हैं आज के टॉपिक को
हालांकि 50 लोग भी यहां पे अभी लाइव में
जॉइन नहीं किया है उन लोगों ने तो मैं
यहां पे 50 पीपल की एटलीस्ट एक्सपेक्टेशन
कर रहा था 100 तो बात ही छोड़ देते हैं तो
मैं य एक बार मैसेज डाल देता
हूं ओके तो यहां पर मैंने मैसेज एक बार
डाल दिया है चलिए अब स्टार्ट करते हैं कोई
बात नहीं अ जितने लोग हैं हम उनके लिए ही
काम करेंगे उनके लिए ही हम अ चीजों को
करेंगे बाकी लोगों से ज्यादा कुछ खास मतलब
है नहीं अब इसलिए फ्रीक्वेंसी जब कम हो
जाती है तो आपको लगता है कि सर इतने लेट
क्यों लाते हो आप खुद ही देखो कि 6000
प्लस पीपल आ हैव जॉइन ऑलमोस्ट 6500 प्लस
पीपल हैव जॉइन द
whatsapp's अकेडमी से और यहां पे 50 लोग
भी जॉइन नहीं किए लाइव सेशन में तो इससे
डिस्क जमेंट हो इससे क्या हो जाता है कि
लगता है कि अरे यार आपको कोई मूड ही नहीं
है एगजैक्टली क्वालिटी सीखने की खुद सोचो
आप लोग 20-20 252 हज 101 हज देके लाइव
ट्रेनिंग करने जाते हो कोचिंग
इंस्टीट्यूट्स कंपनीज वगैरह इन सब में एंड
वहां पे आपको इस तरह की क्वालिटी भी नहीं
मिल पाती है एंड वहां पैसे खर्च करते हो
तो आप जाते हो लेकिन जब पैसा नहीं लग रहा
है तो आप सोच रहे हो कि चलो यार अपने
हिसाब से जब मर्जी तब आ जाते हैं राइट तो
वो वो मेंटालिटी होती है उसको चेंज नहीं
किया जा सकता है ये बेकार सी मेंटालिटी है
बहुत लोगों की राइट राइट राइट वी नीड मोर
वीडियोस तो पहले आया तो करो तभी तो
वीडियोस है ठीक
है संतोष आप बार-बार अगर मैसेज डालेंगे तो
आपको टाइम आउट करना पड़ेगा आप स्पैम कर
रहे एक तरह से राइट लव फ्रॉम पाकिस्तान लव
फ्रॉम इंडिया
ब्रदर ओके संतोष को थोड़ी देर के लिए टाइम
आउट कर देते हैं यहां पे एंड आपकी जो आंसर
है वो भी आंसर भी कर देंगे तो आप टेंशन
फ्री रहिए आप किसी भी वनबिल के लिए जा
सकते हैं जिस वनबिल के लिए आपको लगता है
कि यू आर गुड टू गो यू हैव गुड कैच ऑन दैट
वलने बिलिटी ठीक है तो आज जो है हम
जेडब्ल्यू टोकन हंटिंग करेंगे लाइव हंटिंग
करेंगे बेसिकली यहां पे उसके पहले हम यहां
पे जो हमारा एक पार्ट बचा हुआ है हम उसको
भी कवर करेंगे एंड देन हम लाइव हंटिंग भी
करेंगे यानी कि वी आर गोइंग टू हंट फॉर
हंट लाइव आल्सो तो हम लाइव हंटिंग भी
करेंगे एंड लाइफ टारगेट प हम करेंगे एंड
उसके पहले हम एक ब्रूट फोर्स वाला काम कर
लेते हैं लाइक अगर मान लो लेट्स सपोज कि
आपके पास एक जेडब्ल्यू टोकन आ चुका है ठीक
है हमारा
सिनेरियो
सॉरी हमारा सिनेरियो क्या बनेगा मैं और
सिनेरियो आपको क्रिएट करके बता देता हूं
फर्स्ट स्टेप यू यहां पे मैं इसको बड़ा कर
देता हूं यू फाउंड
अ जेडब्ल्यू t
टोकन ठीक है आपको टोकन मिला जेडब्ल्यू नाउ
आपको जो है यू हैव टू फाइंड सीक्रेट की
आपको सीक्रेट की चाहिए होगा जैसे कि मैंने
पहले ही बताया कि अगर आपके पास सीक्रेट की
नहीं आपके पास जेडब्ल्यू टोकन आ चुका है
और अगर किसी तरह का कोई मिस कॉन्फिन नहीं
है जैसे टोकन वेरिफिकेशन में कोई मिस
कॉन्फिन नहीं है वहां पे या टोकन मान लो
आप डिलीट कर दे रहे हो वहां पे भी आपका
कन्फेशन वहां पे भी सिक्योरिटी लगी है आप
डिलीट करने के बाद वो उस चीज को अ जो है
डिटेक्ट कर रहा है एंड उसको आप बेसिकली
साइन नहीं कर पा रहे हो बेसिकली आप जो है
यूज़ नहीं कर पा रहे हो टोकन को किसी तरह
का चेंजेज नहीं ला पा रहे हो या किसी तरह
का कोई मिस कॉन्फिन नहीं है एंड आपके पास
जेडब्ल्यू टोकन आ चुका है कहीं से आपने
हंट किया है लाइव हंटिंग किया है जो अभी
हम करने वाले हैं और आपके पास जेडब्ल्यूडी
टोकन आ चुका है तो जेडब्ल्यूडी टोकन किसी
भी जेडब्ल्यू टेकन टोकन का अगर आप सीक्रेट
की फाइंड कर लेते हैं तो आप खुद का की जो
है जनरेट करके आप उससे साइन कर सकते हैं
बेसिकली एंड यू कैन साइन दैट टोकन एंड
साइन अगर आप कर पा रहे हैं तो लिटरली क्या
होगा किसी तरह का कोई भी चेंज आप करेंगे
वो एक्सेप्ट कर लिया जाएगा सर्वर के साइट
से तो यानी कि आप जो भी चेंजेज करना
चाहेंगे अ जो भी आप अ इंफॉर्मेशन या जो भी
इंफॉर्मेशन आप बेसिकली चेंज करना चाहेंगे
यूजर का चाहे उसका ईमेल आईडी चेंज करके
अकाउंट टेक ओवर कर लीजिए या कुछ भी वो
बेसिकली क्या होगा सक्सेसफुल जाएगा तो अगर
आपके पास जेडब्ल्यू टोकन मिल चुका है जो
कि हम अभी लाइव टारगेट जब करेंगे हंट तो
उसमें जेडब्ल्यू टोकन फाइंड करने के
देना है
दैट्ची उसके बाद थर्ड अटेंप्ट आपका थर्ड
क्या होगा साइन द साइन
विथ द सीक्रेट की बस हो गया जो भी
सिग्नेचर करनी है वो साइन आप कर सकते हैं
उस टोकन को जो भी आप चेंजेज करते हैं
बेसिकली यह फोर्थ ये फोर्थ पार्ट में आप
इसको ले लीजिए फोर्थ पार्ट में यहां पे
थर्ड में आप इसको डाल सकते
हैं मेक द
चेंजेज एंड उसके बाद आप साइन कर दीजिए
सीक्रेट की से बस यह पूरा का पूरा आपका
अटेंप्ट होता है पूरा का पूरा ये तरीका
आपको होता है ये स्टेप्स होते है ठीक है
अब चलिए इसको हम देखते हैं कि कैसे इसको
हम इनफेक्ट कैसे कर सकते चलिए अब यहां पे
हम आते हैं यहां पे जब आप वेब सिक्योरिटी
पे
जाएंगे तो यहां पे ऑल टॉपिक्स पे चलेंगे
ये बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है इस पे आप ध्यान
दीजिएगा प्लीज एवरी बडी प्लीज फोकस हियर
जब यहां पे एडवांस टॉपिक्स पे जाएंगे
जेडब्ल्यू टैक्स पे हम जब चलेंगे तो यहां
पे जब आप नीचे चलेंगे तो हमने पहले
क्या-क्या देखा था आप देख लीजिए पहले हमने
देखा था कि अगर यहां पे किसी तरह का
अनवेरीफाइड सिग्नेचर है तो उसको कैसे उसके
अनवेरीफाइड सिग्नेचर के थ्रू कैसे बायपास
आप कर सकते हैं जेडब्ल्यू ऑथेंटिकेशन फ्लड
सिग्नेचर वेरिफिकेशन को कैसे बायपास कर
सकते हैं देन आपका जो आता है वह है कि अगर
कोई वीक साइनिंग की यूज हो रही है तो उसको
हम किस तरीके से ब्रूट फोर्स कर सकते हैं
सीक्रेट कीज तो यहां पे ब्रूट फोर्स करने
के लिए बेसिकली हम हैश कट का यूज कर सकते
हैं जॉन द रिपर का यूज कर सकते हैं जो भी
आपको टूल यूज़ करना है पासवर्ड क्रैकिंग
का आप यूज कर सकते हैं फिलहाल हैश कट इज द
मोस्ट पावरफुल अ अ टूल जो आपको क्रैकिंग
प्रोवाइड करता है किसी भी तरह के हैश को
अगर आप क्रैक करना चाहते हैं तो हैश कड इज
जस्ट अमेजिंग जस्ट अमेजिंग और बहुत फास्ट
है बहुत ज्यादा फास्ट होता है ठीक है तो
यहां पे हम एक लैब है उस लैब को यहां पे
ओपन करके देखेंगे कि किस तरीके का ये लैब
है क्या हम इसके अंदर कर सकते हैं जब हम
जाएंगे तो यहां पे आ रहा है दिस लैब यूसेज
और जेडब्ल्यू बेस्ड हम लाइव हंटिंग भी
करेंगे तो बने रहिएगा आराम से शांति से
एकदम और इस चीज को पहले समझिए ताकि लाइव
हंटिंग के टाइम में हमारे पास जो भी
सिनेरियो आएंगे हम उस सिनेरियो को अप्लाई
कर सकते हैं दिस लैब यूसेज अ जेडब्ल्यू
बेस्ड मैकेनिज्म फॉर हैंडलिंग सेशंस इट
यूसेज एन एक्सट्रीमली वीक सीक्रेट की टू
बोथ
सॉरी टू बोथ साइन एंड वेरीफाई टोकेंस ठीक
है दिस कैन बी इजली ब्रूट फोर्स यूजिंग अ
वर्ड लिस्ट ऑफ कॉमन सीक्रेट्स तो यहां पे
वर्ड लिस्ट है यहां पे कॉमन सीक्रेट्स का
जेडब्ल्यूडी सीक्रेट्स का तो यह वर्डलिस्ट
का यूज़ हम कर सकते
हैं टू सॉल्व द लैब फर्स्ट ब्रूट फोर्स द
वेबसाइट सीक्रेट की वंस यू हैव ऑब्टेंड इट
यूज़ इट टू साइन अ मॉडिफाइड सेशन टोकन दैट
गिव्स यू एक्सेस टू द एडमिन पैनल स् एडमिन
पे एंड डिलीट द कार्लोस यूजर बस यही करना
है और कुछ नहीं करना है तो हम एक्सेस लैब
ट एक्सेस कर लेते हैं एंड सबसे पहले मैं
यहां पे अपना मशीन स्टार्ट कर लेता हूं तो
मैं यहां पे अपना नटू मशीन स्टार्ट करूंगा
आप काली को भी यूज कर सकते हैं काली में
हैश कट ऑलरेडी आपको मिल जाएगा तो यहां मैं
नटू को यहां पे मैं डब्ल्यू एएल में
स्टार्ट कर रहा हूं आई एम गोइंग टू यूज इन
w एएल w एएल में u12 आपको अगर इंस्टॉल
करना है या काली इंस्टॉल करना है तो आप
इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं बहुत ही बहुत ही इजी
टू इंस्टॉल बेसिकली आपका हो जाता है राइट
तो मैं यहां पे आरएम करके यहां पे एंड वड
लिस्ट मैं एक यहां पे एक वड लिस्ट को
रिमूव करके फिर से आपके लिए लाऊंगा लाइक
ताकि आपको सारा कुछ क्लियर हो जाए पता चल
जाए ठीक है तो यहां पे मैं नटू मशीन पे
अपने लगड इन आ चुका हूं अगर मैं आपको
दिखाऊं तो ईटीसी ओस रिलीज तो ये आपका नटू
जो है वर्जन 24.0 4 हमारा यहां पे रन हो
रहा है सबसे पहले जब भी आप लॉगइन करते हैं
आप एप्ट अपडेट कमांड चला सकते हैं एंड
यहां पे आपको सुडो यूज करना पड़ेगा तो
यहां पे मैं पासवर्ड डाल के यहां पे
क्योंकि मैं नॉर्मल यूजर से लॉगिन हूं तो
मैंने यहां पे सो एप्ट अपडेट चला दिया है
एंड
दैट्ची राइट किसी भी टोकन का तो यहां पे
हम इस अकाउंट में लॉगइन करेंगे उसके पहले
हम इसको कैप्चर करने के लिए बॉब सूट का
यूज़ करेंगे तो वी विल स्टार्ट द बॉब सूट
कम्युनिटी एडिशन तो लेट्स स्टार्ट द बॉब
सूट कम्युनिटी एडिशन फर्स्ट
तो ये रहा नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट स्टार्ट कर
लेते हैं पहले ठीक
है मैं बता रहा हूं ना आपको इस तरह की
फ्री में अगर इस तरह की कोई चीज मिल जाए
कोई दे दे तो आप
यकीन कर लेना कि कोई दे रहा है अगर कोई
ऐसा दे रहा है तो कोई नहीं देता इतना यहां
पे आई थिंक लाइव कितने हैं यहां पे लाइव
में काफी कम लोग हैं लाइक लिटरली वेरी
वेरी लेस पीपल आर हियर लाइव ठीक है कोई
बात नहीं हम हंटिंग करेंगे लाइव हंटिंग भी
करेंगे अ उनको देखो यहां पे क्या
मेंटालिटी क्या है अ कि जब हम लाइव हंटिंग
करेंगे तो उसके पहले हमें सारी चीजें पता
होनी चाहिए तो हमने मिस कन्फेशन का देखा
ब्रूट फोर्स का हमें अभी नहीं पता है तो
वी आर जस्ट सीइंग द ब्रूट फोर्स एंड देन
हम लाइव हंटिंग को स्टार्ट करेंगे राइट बट
स्टिल काफी लोग जो है वो शायद अभी सोच रहे
हैं कि चलो लाइव हंटिंग वाली जो पार्ट है
उसी को सिर्फ देखेंगे तो ऐसे लोग कभी भी
कोई भी किसी भी तरह की बाउंट नहीं ले सकते
हैं कभी भी फ्यूचर में इट्स माय गारंटी
क्योंकि दे आर नॉट एक्चुअली वेरी मच
डेडिकेट फॉर द बग हंटिंग थिंग उनको बस
चाहिए कि लाइव प्रैक्टिकल कुछ बस हो जाए
सामने बस ट्स इट उससे ज्यादा उनको कोई
मतलब नहीं है तो ऐसे लोगों के लिए यह
सीरीज है भी नहीं है तो ऐसे लोग अगर नहीं
है तो इट्स गुड इट्स गुड फॉर अस राइट तो
ये सही है राइट अभी आप देख सकते हैं कि 26
पीपल आर ओनली देयर राइट
आप हां नो इशू कोई बात नहीं बैटमैन
जी ओके लव यू
ब्रदर यस यस आप पूछ सकते हैं कोई दिक्कत
नहीं आप पूछ सकते हैं बिल्कुल आप पूछ सकते
हैं कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है ठीक
है तो हमने बब शूट को ओपन कर लिया यहां पे
जेडब्ल्यू एडिटर प्लगइन जो है आपको लग
इंस्टॉल करके रखना है जैसा कि मैंने पहले
भी बताया था इसके फर्स्ट पार्ट में आपको
बताया था ऑलरेडी नहीं आपको पता है तो
एक्सटेंशन प जाके आप बी एप स्टोर प जाके
यहां पर आप जेडब्ल्यू सर्च
करेंगे तो जेडब्ल्यू वाली जो प्लगइन है य
प जेडब्ल्यू एडिटर यह मिल जाएगी इसको आपको
यहां पर इंस्टॉल कर लेना है ठीक है चलिए
तो अब जो है हम यहां पे
बॉब का प्रॉक्सी इनेबल कर देते हैं माय
अकाउंट प चलते हैं लॉगइन करते हैं यहां पे
एंड लॉगइन करने के लिए विनर डब्लू आई ई एन
ई आर विनर डालते हैं पी ई टीई आर पीटर
डालते हैं यहां पे यहां पे लॉगइन पे क्लिक
कर लेते हैं जैसे हमने लॉगइन किया वी विल
सी द एटीटीपी हिस्ट्री टैब एंड इफ व विल
सी लाइ कोई ग्रीन कलर में अगर हमें कोई
मिलता है जेडब्ल्यू ऑथेंटिकेशन कुछ टोकन
वगैरह तो यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं य पे
माय अकाउंट वाली जो हमारी यूआरएल है यहां
पे आपको कुकीज के अंदर में एक सेशन कुकी
जो है यहां पे आप उसके अंदर आप देख सकते
हैं कि जेडब्ल्यू
t के टोकन आपको यहां पे मिल जाते हैं राइट
सो वी गट द जेडटी टोकन अब हमें इसको
रिपीटर को भेजना पड़ेगा सेंड टू रिपीटर
रिपीटर पे चलते हैं रिपीटर पे जैसे ही
आएंगे वी विल जस्ट ट्राई टू सेंड दिस एंड
सी द रिस्पांस तो रिस्पांस 200 ओके आ रहा
है यहां पे नीचे की तरफ आएंगे तो अ वी विल
सी द रिजल्ट्स राइट अब यहां पे सबसे
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज क्या है मैं आपको बताता
हूं जेसन बब टोकन पे आप आएंगे यहां पे तो
यू विल सी कि यहां प हेडर के अंदर में के
आईडी एल्गोरिदम एचएस 256 एंड यहां पे इ
पोर्ट्सविगर एक्सपायरी एंड यहां पे सब
विनर जो है यहां पे यूजर जो है विनर वो
आपको यहां पे दिख रहा है राइट चलिए अब
हमें यहां पे इसके एडमिन पैनल को एक्सेस
करना है एंड कार्लोस यूजर को डिलीट करनी
है राइट सो अगर हम यहां पे एडमिन पैनल स्ल
एडमिन को एक्सेस करने की कोशिश करेंगे एंड
यहां पे सेंड प क्लिक करेंगे तो यहां पर
रिस्पांस में आपको आएगा यहां पे आप देख
सकते हैं कि एडमिन इंटरफेस ओनली अवेलेबल
इफ लॉग इन एज एन एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर से लॉगइन है तभी ये
इंटरफेस अवेलेबल है अदर वाइज नहीं है राइट
तो व्हाट वी कैन डू वी कैन जस्ट ट्राई टू
चेंज द जसन वेब टोकन वैल्यूज ठीक है तो हम
यहां पे आ जाते हैं अब हम यहां पे जब आप
आएंगे तो यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं कि यहां
सब जो है विनर है इसको हमें एडमिन जो है
वो चेंज करनी है वी हैव टू चेंज इट टू
एडमिन फिलहाल के लिए हम प्रीवियस अपने अ
उस परे चले जाते हैं एंड यहां पे जब आप
पलट को सिलेक्ट करेंगे जब जैसे हमने पहले
देखा था सेशन में पलट को सिलेक्ट करेंगे
तो आप यहां पे देखेंगे कि सब विनर यहां पे
आपका रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा है जैसे ऑन वेब
टोकन पे भी आप आएंगे तो यहां पे विनर
रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा है राइट नाउ व्हाट वी
हैव टू डू द नेक्स्ट स्टेप नेक्स्ट स्टेप
देख लेते
हैं टू सॉल्व द लैब फर्स्ट ब्रूट फोर्स द
वेबसाइट सीक्रेट की वंस यू हैव ऑब्टेन दिस
यूज इट टू साइन अ मॉडिफाइड सेशन आपको क्या
है ब्रूट फोर्स करना है सीक्रेट की को ठीक
है तो भैया अब यहां पे सीक्रेट की हमारी
जो है उसको ब्रूट फोर्स करनी है तो जेसन
टोकन जो है आपका ये इसको हमें ब्रूट फोर्स
करना है यू हैव टू जस्ट ब्रूट फोर्स इट इफ
वयी कैन फाइंड समथिंग काइंड ऑफ राइट तो
यहां पे हम चलते हैं यहां पे हम पूरी जेसन
टोकन जो है इसको लॉगिन इसको हम कॉपी कर
लेते हैं ठीक है हमने जेसन को यहां पे
टोकन को लॉगिन कॉपी कर लिया है अब हम इसे
किस तरीके से ब्रूट फोर्स करते हैं हम
उसको देख लेते हैं ठीक है ब्रूट फोर्स
करने के लिए हमें चाहिए एक टूल जिसका नाम
है हैश कैट ठीक है है कट टूल को यूज़ करने
के लिए सिंपली आपको इंस्टॉल करना है है कट
एंड यू कैन जस्ट स्टार्ट ब्रूट फोसिंग तो
जब आप यवन टू या काली पे हैं तो आप एप्ट अ
जो है अ उससे इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं हैश कट
को तो मैं अगर देखूं यहां पे तो सो ए गेट
इंस्टॉल हैश कट तो यहां पे आप जब देखोगे
तो यहां हैश कट ऑलरेडी इंस्टॉल्ड है आप
चाहे तो ऐप इंस्टॉल है कट से इंस्टॉल कर
सकते हैं राइट वी जस्ट इंस्टॉल इट अब यहां
पे क्लियर इसको कर देता हूं मैं अब मैं
हैश कट को जब रन करूंगा हैश
कट इस तरीके से h h तो इसकी हेल्प फाइल
मुझे आ
जाएगी कुछ इस तरीके से यह पूरी की पूरी
हेल्प फाइल आ रही है हैकेट को यूज़ करने
के लिए सबसे पहले आपको अटैक मोड चूज करना
पड़ता है जो कि आप ऑप्शन लगा सकते हैं
यहां पे हान a से देन आपको हैश टाइप
डिफाइन करना पड़ता है देन आपको टोकन जो भी
आपका अ टोकन है या जो भी आप जिस पे भी आप
ब्रूट फोर्स करना चाहते हैं व आप डिफाइन
करेंगे एंड फिर वर्डलिस्ट जो है आपकी
डिक्शनरी जो है वो डिक्शनरी आपको डिफाइन
करनी पड़ती है यानी कि हैश करर दीजिए उसके
बाद ऑप्शंस को यूज कीजिए उसके बाद जो भी
अग हैश वैल्यू है या कोई हैश फाइल है तो
उसको डिफाइन कीजिए एंड देन डिक्शनरी या
आपका वर्ड लिस्ट है उसको डिफाइन कीजिए तो
सबसे पहले हमें एक वर्ड लिस्ट चाहिए एक
बढ़िया वर्ड लिस्ट चाहिए तो वर्डलिस्ट के
लिए मैं यहां पे मैंने एक
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
इज कंपलीटली ब्लैंक तो मैं एक वर्डलिस्ट
को यहां पे लाता हूं जेडब्ल्यू t टोकेंस
ब्रूट फोर्स करने के लिए तो वर्डलिस्ट का
यहां पे यूआरएल ऑलरेडी दिया हुआ है
इन्होंने तो यह वर्डलिस्ट ये यूज़ कर र है
इसी वर्डलिस्ट को हम डाउनलोड कर लेंगे तो
मैं यहां रॉ फॉर्मेट में चलता हूं इसका
एग्जैक्ट यूआरएल कॉपी कर लेता हूं एंड
इसको हम डाउनलोड कर लेते हैं डब्ल्यू गेट
कमांड से तो डब्लू गेट कमांड डाला यहां पे
ये डाला एंड एंटर किया उसके बाद यह
वर्डलिस्ट डाउनलोड हो जाएगी एंड जब आप
एलएस करके देखेंगे तो
jwt.io करके डब् स हान l करेंगे तो आपको
इसके अंदर की टोटल एंट्री आ जाएगी देन यह
है
10975 ठीक है इतनी एंट्रीज है ऑलमोस्ट तो
इसको आप इससे मैच भी कर सकते हैं अगर
एंट्री अगर आप देखनी है तो यहां पे भी 103
975 एंट्रीज है यहां पे इतने आपके पास
वर्ड लिस्ट आ चुके हैं नाउ वी कैन यूज़
दिस वर्ड लिस्ट एक्चुअली सो अब हमें यूज़
कैसे करना है तो हमें यहां पे देना है हैश
कट कमांड देना है उसके बाद अटैक मोड न a
आपको चूज करनी है अटैक मोड जो है मैं जीरो
यूज करता हूं यहां पे एंड हान m से आप हैश
टाइप डिफाइन करते हैं अब जब हैश कड हान h
करेंगे
आप तो मैं यहां पे चलता हूं
ऊपर एंड यहां आप जब अटैक मोड देखेंगे तो
यहां पे जीरो अटैक मोड इज स्ट्रेट मोड
सीधा स्ट्रेट मोड आपको यूज करना है तो हम
यूज कर सकते हैं आप चाहे तो आप ब्रूट
फोर्स भी यूज कर सकते हैं वो आपके ऊपर
आपकी मर्जी है बट यहां पे हैश टाइप आपको
दिखाना है अब हैश टाइप में ना यहां पे हम
जेडब्ल्यू टोकन को ब्रूट फोर्स कर रहे हैं
तो हमें जेडब्ल्यू टोकन यहां पे डिफाइन
करनी पड़ेगी हैश टाइप में तो यहां पे हम
देखते हैं जेडब्ल्यू टोकन का क्या है
नेटवर्क प्रोटोकॉल के अंदर आएगा तो यहां
पे आप देखेंगे जेडटी वेब टोकेंस के लिए
इसका जो
हैश बेसिकली जो ये वैल्यू है 16500 16500
है यहां पे यह आपकी वैल्यू तो 16500 जो है
आप हैश मोड वैल्यू को यूज करेंगे
जेडब्ल्यूडी टोकेंस के लिए तो मैं यहां पे
नीचे चलता हूं एंड अब कमांड यहां पे हम
जनरेट करते हैं कमांड क्या जनरेट करेंगे
हैश कट
हाइन अटैक मोड जीरो हान ए हैश वैल्यू जो
है 16500 जेडटी टोकेंस के लिए राइट उसके
बाद जो है हम यहां पे टोकन जो हमें
बेसिकली
अ जिसपे ब्रूट फोर्स हमें करना है उस टोकन
को यहां पे हम प्रोवाइड करेंगे तो हमारे
पास टोकन ऑलरेडी है यहां से मेरे पास यह
टोकन है तो मैं इसको यहां से कॉपी कर लेता
हूं मैं यहां पे इसको पेस्ट कर देता हूं
टोकन को आपने पेस्ट किया या हैश वैल्यू
बेसिकली हैश वैल्यू जो है उसको पेस्ट किया
उसके बाद यहां पे आपको देनी होती है
वर्डलिस्ट की पाथ तो वर्डलिस्ट का जो पाथ
है वो है अ स्लश वर्डलिस्ट के अंदर अ नहीं
ये ये जो वर्ड लिस्ट है ये मेरे अ जो
पर्टिकुलर डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
स्टार्ट हो जाएगा एंड इट विल ब्रूट फोर्स
तो यहां पे क्योंकि यह बहुत फास्ट काम
करता है लोकली आपका काम करता है तो आपने
यहां देखा कि डिक्शनरी लिस्ट जो है वो
बिल्ड हुई है यहां से आई है टोटल पासवर्ड
इतने पासवर्ड्स हैं ठीक है एंड यहां पे ये
जो फॉर्मेट है जेडटी एंड कॉलन एंड सीक्रेट
एंड जो भी आपका सीक्रेट है वो सीक्रेट आ
चुका है तो यहां पे जो वैल्यू आई है वो
सीक्रेट वन आई है यानी कि हमारा जो की है
वो है सीक्रेट वन तो हमने इसको क्रैक कर
लिया आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे क्रैक का आ
चुका है यहां पे एंड वी हैव क्रैक्ड द
सीक्रेट की तो इट्स सीक्रेट वन तो सीक्रेट
वन हमारे पास आ चुका है नाउ वी हैव द
की सीक्रेट वन ठीक है सो पहला हमने काम कर
लिया हमने ब्रूट फोर्स जो है वो कर लिया
है वी हैव जस्ट ब्रूट फोर्स राइट अब रूट
फोर्स हमने कर लिया अब हम आगे की तरफ
बढ़ते हैं नेक्स्ट जो हमारा पार्ट
है स्टेप है कि आपको इसको यूज करना है
साइन करने के लिए तो अब साइन कैसे करेंगे
आप मैं आपको इसका तरीका बता देता हूं साइन
कैसे करेंगे ऐसे साइन आप नहीं कर पाएंगे
जैसे कि अब क्या करते हैं ना हम क्या करते
हैं यहां पे जेसन वेब टोकेंस पे जाएंगे
एंड यहां पे इस वैल्यू को साइन करने से
पहले हमें जेडब्ल्यूडी ए एडिटर पे चलना है
जेडब्ल्यूडी एडिटर पे चलके हम एक न्यू
सिमेट्री की क्रिएट करेंगे राइट न्यू
सिमेट्री क्रिएट करेंगे तो यहां पे जो है
बेसिकली अ बेसिकली हम आई एक सिमेट्री की
जनरेट करेंगे बट जो हम जनरेट करेंगे तो जो
की वैल्यू आएगी उसको हम इनकोड ड करके यूज
करेंगे तो हम यहां पे बॉब के डिकोडर पे
चलेंगे यहां पे हम अपना जो सीक्रेट वन है
इसको पेस्ट करेंगे और इसको हम इनकोड
करेंगे बेस 64 में क्योंकि बेस 64
इनकोडिंग यूज होती है जब भी आप सीक्रेट की
की बात करते हैं तो बेस 64 इनकोडिंग आपका
यूज होता है तो हम इनकोड बेस 64 में
करेंगे बेस 64 में इनकोड कर देंगे तो
हमारे पास इनकोडेड वैल्यू आ जाएगी इसको
कॉपी कर लेंगे अब हम जेडब्ल्यू एडिटर प
चलेंगे न्यू सिमेट्री की करेंगे यहां पे
एक सिमेट्री की जनरेट करेंगे एंड जो k
वैल्यू है आपकी जो की वैल्यू यहां पे है
इसको हम से रिप्लेस कर देंगे जो हमारा बेस
64 इनकोडेड वैल्यू हमने निकाला है इससे
करके हम यहां पे इसको ओके कर देंगे एंड
हमारी की जो है ये जनरेट हो चुकी है सो वी
हैव द की जनरेट 8c 4 डीडी करके ऐसे करके
अब हम रिपीटर पे चलेंगे अब हम यहां पे
चेंजेज करेंगे वी विल जस्ट मेक द चेंजेज
तो यहां पे जब हम चेंजेज करेंगे तो यहां
पे सब जो है यहां पे आपका विनर है तो
व्हाट वी विल डू वी विल मेक इट
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर हमने एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर कर
दिया दैट टोटली फाइन यहां पे अ
दैट्ची 4 डीडी साइनिंग की आपकी आ चुकी है
डॉट मोडिफाइड है ये ठीक है चलेगा यहां पे
एंड यहां पे hs256 एल्गोरिदम है यहां पे
hs256 एल्गोरिदम हमने ऑलरेडी चूज कर रखा
है यहां पे हम ओके पे क्लिक करेंगे जैसे
ही हम ओके पे क्लिक करेंगे आपकी जो ये
पर्टिकुलर टोकन है ये साइन हो चुकी है अब
हम रॉ फॉर्मेट पे जाएंगे यहां पे एंड यहां
पे बेसिकली वी विल ट्राई टू एक्सेस द
एडमिन पैनल नाउ अब हम एडमिन पैनल जो है
एक्सेस करेंगे ट्राई करेंगे एक्सेस करने
की बट उसके पहले जब हम इस पेलोड को यहां
से इस तरीके से कॉपी करेंगे तो आप देखेंगे
यहां पे कि अब सब एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर हो चुका
है अब हम इसको सिंपली क्या करेंगे यहां से
एडमिन पैनल को एक्सेस करने की कोशिश
करेंगे वी विल ट्राई टू एक्सेस एडमिन पैनल
देन वी विल सेंड इट देन वी विल सेंड तो
हमें यहां पर रिस्पांस मिलेगा 200 ओके का
जब हम नीचे की तरफ जाएंगे तो वी कैन सी सी
दैट अ या वी गॉट द लिंक हियर एडमिन डिलीट
यूजर नेम विनर एडमिन डिलीट यूजर नेम
कार्लोस तो इसको हम सिंपली कॉपी कर लेंगे
अभी आप देखेंगे कि यहां पे अभी आपका लैब
सॉल्व नहीं हुआ है इट्स नॉट सॉल्वड यट सो
वी विल जस्ट एक्सेस दिस पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल
तो हमने ये यूआरएल का जो टोटल एड्रेस है
वो डाल दिया यहां पे सेंड करेंगे एंड वी
विल सी दैट कांग्रेचुलेशन यू सॉल्व द लैब
तो हमने क्या किया बेसिकली जेडब्ल्यूडी पे
हमने यहां पे हैच कट का यूज़ किया हमने
उसको क्रैक किया उस अ की अ की को उसके बाद
उसकी को हमने जब क्रैक किया तो फिर हमने
उसको यूज किया साइन किया हमने टोकन को एंड
जो भी चेंजेज थे वो चेंजेज किए साइन किए
साइन करने के बाद हम यहां पे एडमिन पैनल
को एक्सेस कर सकते हैं जब आप फॉलो
रीडायरेक्शन करेंगे तो यू कैन गेट द रेंडर
वर्जन यहां पे कि यहां पे आपको कार्लोस जो
है वो गायब मिलेगा सिर्फ विनर यूजर आपको
मिलेगा कांग्रेचुलेशन सॉल्व द लैब सो हमने
यह लैब को सॉल्व कर दिया बहुत देखो लैब
सॉल्व तो हमने कर दिया आपको वैसे इजी लग
रहा होगा बट एक्चुअली दिस इज क्वाइट
ट्रिकी ट्रिक ट्र पार्ट है ये ठीक है काफी
ट्रिकी पार्ट है तो ये बताइए
मुझे जो गट हल फेम टैग यू ऑन लिंकन बट नो
रिप्लाई कोई आपको रिप्लाई मिलेगा ब्रदर और
कभी-कभी हम थोड़ा
सा छूट जाता है कोई पोस्ट अगर टैग होता है
तो बट हम जरूर करेंगे आपको ठीक है
रिप्लाई ओके ओके
ग्रेट ओके
चलिए कोई बात नहीं आप इंफर्म कर दीजिएगा
टे ग्रा पे ऑफिशियल अंडर टीएन पे हैकर जी
हम उसको इन्वेस्टिगेट कर लेंगे
राइट राइट सो नो
वरीज या राइट राइट राइट तो ये यहां तक
आपको समझ में आ गया यहां तक आपको समझ में
आ गया जो हमने ब्रूट फोर्स किया है ताकि
हम लाइव हंटिंग की तरफ अब आगे प्रोसीड
करें ठीक है अब जो लोग यहां पे हैं उनको
लाइव हंटिंग मिलेगी जो लोग नहीं है उनको
नहीं मिलेगी यार सिंपल एज दैट
राइट जल्दी बता दीजिए सो एवरीवन अंडरस्टूड
सभी को समझ में आ गया यहां तक एक बार
रिप्लाई कर दीजिए तब मजा आएगा और लाइक
रिप्लाई करने के साथ-साथ लाइक ठोकते चले
जाइएगा जिन्होने नहीं किया है ठीक है
रिप्लाई रिप्लाई रिप्लाई जल्दी रिप्लाई
करो जल्दी फटाफट रिप्लाई रिप्लाई आई एम
वेटिंग फॉर द रिप्लाई यहां पे 45 पीपल है
कम से कम यार 20 2 लोग तो रिप्लाई
करो गट यू अंडरस्टूड
चलिए ओके
ओके तो ऑलमोस्ट सब लोग बोल रहे हैं कि हां
अंडरस्टूड है यहां पे हमने ब्रूट फोर्सिंग
किया
राइट रिप्लाई भी नहीं कर रहे रिप्लाई भी
नहीं कर
रहे कोई बात नहीं
चलिए चलिए ठीक है डन तो यहां पे हमारा ये
काम हो चुका है ब्रूट फोर्सिंग हमने यहां
पे कर दिया है एंड वी आर डन फॉर नाउ तो ये
वाला काम हम वाला काम हमारा खत्म हो चुका
है वी आर नॉट डूइंग एनी काइंड ऑफ लैब्स
फॉर नाउ तो
दैट्ची जम जेडब्ल्यू टोकेंस को फाइंड करने
की कोशिश करेंगे वी विल सी दैट पर्टिकुलर
थिंग तो यहां पे मैं बब शूट को फिलहाल के
लिए क्लोज कर देता हूं बब सूट प्रॉक्सी को
डिसेबल कर देता हूं एंड यहां पे मैं सिंपल
अब हम आते हैं लाइव हंटिंग को स्टार्ट
करते हैं एंड हमें अब क्या करना है हमें
एक टारगेट को चूज करना है फॉर जेडब्ल्यू
टोकन जहां पर
हमें साइनिंग साइन अप लॉग इन जितने
फंक्शनालिस है सबको एक्सप्लोर करना है एंड
देखना है कि कहीं पे जेडब्ल्यू टोकन हमें
मिल रहा है क्या या हम फाइंड कर पा रहे
हैं क्या द फर्स्ट थिंग सेकंड थिंग कि हम
एक डोमेन पे सिर्फ डिपेंड नहीं रह सकते
हमें ट्राई करना है एज मच डोमेन वी कैन
फाइंड एज मच सब डोमेन वी कैन एक्सप्लोर
हमें सब डोमेन को एक्सप्लोर करना है हम
सडन यूज करेंगे हम एसटीटीपी एक् लाइव
डोमेन निकाले सब चीजें करेंगे तो पहले हम
एक टारगेट सिलेक्ट कर लेते हैं ठीक है सो
लेट्स गो एंड फाइंड अ टारगेट अ सूटेबल
टारगेट तो हम यहां पर बकरा आउट प चलते हैं
चलिए सो लेट्स गो टू द बकरा
राइट ग्रेट बहुत अच्छी बहुत अच्छी बात है
बहुत सी बात
है
ओके आई एम फर्स्ट टू द चैनल्स व्हाट यू
टीच सर आप देख लीजिए सुमित चैनल पे देखिए
आपको पता चल जाएगा कि हम क्या पढ़ाते हैं
राइट
ओके ओके तो यहां पे हम चलते हैं हैकर वन
एंड बकट दो प्लेटफॉर्म्स हम यूज कर सकते
हैं एसवी हैक भी आप यूज कर सकते हैं व्हाट
एवर यहां से हम कोई भी टारगेट एक उठाएंगे
अपना जो भी टारगेट आप चाहते हैं उठाइए
हैकर वन से उठाना है तो आप रिसर्चर पे
जाके
अ एक्टिविटी पे आप जा सकते हैं बेसिकली
एक्टिविटी
सेक्शन प एक बार चल लेते हैं यहां से भी
आप कोई टारगेट अगर रिसेंट कोई टारगेट
उठाना चाहते हैं जो टार्गेट आप रिसेंट लोग
रिपोर्ट जिन्होंने किया उसको उठा सकते हैं
या तो आप डायरेक्टरी में चलके आप
डायरेक्टरी से भी टारगेट को उठा सकते हैं
फिल्टर आउट कर सकते हैं तो हम यहां पे
पहली तो वाइल्ड कार्ड टारगेट को उठाएंगे
जहां पे मल्टीपल सब डोमेंस जो है वो उसके
अंदर हो दूसरे बाद हम हैकर न मैनेज्ड वाले
टारगेट को बिल्कुल नहीं उठाएंगे क्योंकि
हैकर न मैनेज्ड वाले में बहुत नाटक है
बहुत तरह की दिक्कतें हैं मतलब छोटी-मोटी
चीजों को वलने बिलिटी को एक्सेप्ट ही नहीं
कर करते लाइक थोड़ा बहुत अगर वो है भी
लेबिलिटी एंड उसमें जब तक आप प्रॉपर एक
इंपैक्ट नहीं दिखाएंगे ना दे विल नॉट
गोइंग टू एक्सेप्ट इट तो आप इस तरीके से
नॉन मैनेज वाली जो प्रोग्राम है उसको आप
उठा सकते हैं इफ यू वांट ठीक है उसके बाद
बक राउड प आप जाएंगे तो बक राउड प आपको
अलग-अलग यहां पर मिलेगा इसमें से कोई सा
भी आप उठा सकते हो राइट यू कैन जस्ट चूज
एनी ब कॉमर्स भी मैं ले सकता हूं इट्स अ
गुड टारगेट
यर तो यहां पे
सेकंड पेज को देख लेते
हैं नेक्स्ट अप एआई करके है इनको हम ले
सकते हैं यहां पर एस टारगेट में नेक्स्ट
टारगेट
कैफीन इसको यूज कर सकते हैं वन शॉपिंग
कार्ट इसको भी हम ले सकते हैं पॉ शॉपिंग
कार्ड को ए द टारगेट ठीक है पिक्सेल जो है
इसको य तो चलिए यहां पे बग कॉमर्स है
हमारे पास बग कॉमर्स में जब आप टारगेट पे
देखेंगे तो हमारे पास वाइल का टारगेट होना
चाहिए वाइल का टारगेट यहां पे ये जो एस्ट
रिस्क लगा है इन टारगेट्स के ऊपर हंट करना
ज्यादा अच्छा होता है क्योंकि आपके पास
मल्टीपल डोमेंस हो जाते हैं इस डोमेन इसका
सब डोमेन फिर वहां पे पेजेस आप निकालेंगे
अलग-अलग फाइंड करेंगे तो आपके पास
अपॉर्चुनिटी जो है वो ज्यादा हो जाती है
उसी तरह नेक्स्ट आप पीआई में जाएंगे तो ये
तो पॉज हो चुका है तो इसको हम वैसे भी हटा
देते हैं ये पॉज है वन शॉपिंग कार्ड
बिल्कुल प्रोग्रेस में है आप इस पे जाएंगे
तो आप देखेंगे यहां पे कि बेसिकली one
shoping.com डोमेन में है अ स्कोप में है
एंड यहां पे mcs-swa
कॉ जो है मेन डोमेन को भी आप यहां पे कर
सकते हैं चलिए यहां पे और जो याद रखिएगा
कि one शि cart.com के सब डोमस आउट ऑफ
स्कोप में इन्होंने डाला हुआ है तो इट्स
नॉट अ गुड काइंड ऑफ थिंग आपका टारगेट तो
यहां पे टारगेट अब हैकर वन से हम देखते
हैं एक और टारगेट उठाते हैं कोई भी एक
और कोहो कोहो को देखते हैं यहां पे
रीटेस्टिंग एंड कोलबेन व्हाट इज दिस कोहो
सो देखते हैं इनका क्या है स्कोप एरिया
क्या है कोहो में स्कोप में चलते हैं एंड
स्कोप में चलेंगे जब आप
तो स्कोप में
कोहो एपीआई
वेब वे इ द वाइल्ड कार्ड कोड सी एंड आउट
स्कोप है यह तो यहां पे कुछ खास वाइल्ड
कार्ड आपको नहीं मिल रही है तो व विल जस्ट
लीव इट जस्ट गो टू अनदर
टारगेट अ दूसरे टारगेट जैसे
flipkart.com को भी यूज कर सकते हैं वी
कैन यूज द jio.com डोमेन आल्सो तो jio.com
अगर आप देखेंगे तो
jio.com तो व्हाट वी डू वंस एन एप्लीकेशन
रिपोर्टेड टू अस j इनकरेज रिस्पांसिबल
डिस्क्लोजर ऑफ सिक्योरिटी बक्स बाय
सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चर ठीक है ऑल बक्स एंड
सिरिटी आर रिपोर्टेड टू यूज तो यह भी आप
यूज़ कर सकते हैं बट वही है कि फिर इसमें
आपको बेसिकली लन वगैरह करना पड़ेगा तो
लॉगइन करने के लिए आप यहां पे मोबाइल नंबर
ही आप यूज कर सकते हैं राइट तो मोबाइल
नंबर आप यूज करके देन यू कैन जस्ट लॉग इन
तो यह काम एक करना पड़ेगा तो इसको अभी
फिलहाल के लिए छोड़ देते हैं हम कोई और
यूज कर सकते हैं राइट कोई और टारगेट हम ले
लेंगे यहां से j के अलावा
रखेंगे अपने पास ट्रस्ट फाइनेंसियल या वी
कैन यूज शटर फ्लाई वीडीपी भी यूज हम
वीडीपी यूज कर सकते ले सकते हैं न एन इशू
बट देखते हैं इन ड्राइव को देखते हैं क्या
है यह इन ड्राइव प चलते
हैं यहां पे स्कोप में चलते हैं इड्राइव
के एंड लेट्स फाइंड आउट व्ट इज द स्कोप सो
इड्राइव j.com एंड वा कार्ड इ देयर ट्स
ग्रेट यह अच्छी चीज
है इन . का भी यहां पे पूरा इंक्लूडेड है
सब डोमेन वगैरह सब कुछ इंक्लूडेड है यह भी
अच्छी बात हो गई हमारे लिए अ इड्राइव कॉ
ये भी अच्छी बात है तो ind.com दिस डोमेन
इज एंड ऑल वाइल काड एंट्रीज आर वो तो इ
drive.com पे चल देते हैं यहां पे आई थिंक
लॉगइन का ऑप्शन होना चाहिए इ दे लॉगइन
ऑप्शन
अ आई थिंक वेब पे कोई लॉगिन शायद नहीं है
आई डोंट थिंक सो राइट या स नो एनी वेब
लॉगिन यर तो हमारे कुछ काम का यहां पर
नहीं है इन के चलिए दूसरा टारगेट हम ले
लेते इनका ल जस्ट टेक अनदर टारगेट ऑफ
इड्राइव राइट हम इसका इन ड्राइव का दूसरा
टारगेट लेते तो इड्राइव में एक और हमारे
पास वाइल कार्ड है इनड्राइवर
कॉ तो इनड्राइवर कॉम को देख लेते हैं इफ
देर सम काइंड ऑफ लॉगिन और समथिंग
ना दे नो लॉगइन
[संगीत]
फंक्शनालिस
यर
नस ओके ओके ओके ओके ड्राइड आओ प चलते हैं
ड आओ प व कैन फाइंड
समथिंग कुछ और ले लेते हैं यहां पर मरो
मरो प जा सकते हैं ठीक है मरो प चलते हैं
कीवी ड कॉ मैनेज हैय तो छोड़ देते हैं कीड
कॉ को मैनेज यूएस डिपार्टमेंट स्टेट
डिफेंस का वह भी मैनेज है य भी मैनेज है
मैनेज
है फिडिलिटी मैनेज है यहां
पर सो इंस्टा कार्ड इ आल्सो मैनेज कुछ तोन
मैनेज मिल जा
भाई ंडर इ
मैनेज चलो इसको देख लेते हैं स्कोप पर
चलते हैं य पर मरो पे व्हाट इज
द फइल काड प मेरो कॉ मिरो मिरो मिरो कॉ
ठीक है मिरो कॉ ओके ओके ओके दे नो वाइल्ड
कार्ड हमारे काम का वाइल्ड कार्ड तो कुछ
है नहीं यहां पे सो जस्ट लीव इट एक तो
हमें यहां से चाहिए ही चाहिए तो कोई सा भी
एक तो हमें उठाना है चाहे कुछ भी हो जाए
ऑन भी है यहां पे क्राइम मैनेज्ड है
एक्सोडस जी है हमारे नेटलीफ वो मैनेज्ड य
कैन जस्ट ट्राई फाइंड आउट बट
फिलहाल के लिए य पर रहने देते हैं रो
ब्लक्स आल्सो एचसीएल सॉफ्टवेयर भी मैनेज
है
ट एल सॉफ्टवेयर हमें लगा कि
मैनेज उठा लेते इसको मैनेज सॉलिड
लेट्स सी सॉलिड व्ट इ सॉलिड लेट्स
सी चलिए सॉलिड में चलते स्कोप प चलते
हैं वाइल्ड कार्ड आउट ऑफ स्कोप कर दिया
इन्होने क्या बात है भाई क्या बात है
वाइल्ड वाइल्ड कार्ड को
आउट स्कोप रखने की कोई मतलब नहीं है शिफ
क्रिप्टो कॉ गोल्डन स् वर्डप्रेस
कोलैबोरेशन है वर्डप्रेस में हां जी हां
जी हां जी तो वर्डप्रेस में भी हम ट्राई
आउट कर सकते हैं
[संगीत]
हालाकि जमेटो है जमेटो इज आल्सो देयर
स्विगी इ आल्सो देयर अगर स्विगी इफ वी कैन
फाइंड द स्विगी समथिंग लाइक दैट राइट वो
भी यहां प तो चलिए फिलहाल के लिए हमारे
पास एक जो
है बिग com.com एक जो टारगेट है हम उसपे
फिलहाल के लिए फोकस करते हैं bc.com पे आई
होप यहां पे लॉगइन
फंक्शनालिस गो एंड यहां पे या ब कॉमर्स पे
यहां पे लॉगिन फंक्शनैलिटीज आर देयर यहां
पे आप साइन अप वगैरह भी कर सकते हैं सो
दैट्ची वो हम देखेंगे राइट bc.com पे हमने
यहां पे ओपन कर लिया है तो आवर फर्स्ट
टारगेट हैज बीन डिफाइंड एज ब कर्स राइट तो
अब सबसे पहले क्या करना होता है कि आपको
इसकी सब डोमेंस को फाइंड करनी है जितने सब
डोमेंस आप फाइंड कर सकते हैं यू हैव टू
फाइंड द सब डोमेंस एंड फिर
google2 से भी हम ट्राई करेंगे तो सबसे
पहले तो हम अ इसके सब डोमेन को फाइंड करते
हैं सब डोमेन फाइंड करने के लिए जो द
इंपोर्टेंट टूल जो अगर आप लोगों ने पहले
से बग बाउंट की सीरीज को फॉलो करा है तो
आपको पता होगा कि सब डोमेन फाइंड करने के
लिए हम सब फाइंडर टूल का यूज कर सकते हैं
वी कैन यूज अ सब फाइंडर टूल वेरी
इंटरेस्टिंग टूल सब फाइंडर को इंस्टॉल अगर
करना है आपको तो कुछ नहीं करना होता है सब
फाइंडर के गिट हब रिपोजिटरी पे आप
जाइएगा सब फाइंडर गिट अप करके यहां पे ओपन
कीजिएगा यहां जब इंस्टॉलेशन पे जाइएगा तो
आप सिंपल एक कमांड से गो इंस्टॉल कमांड से
इसको कॉपी करेंगे एंड इसको आप टर्मिनल पे
पेस्ट करके इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं उसके पहले
आपका गो ग लैंग्वेज गोलंग जो इंस्टॉल होना
चाहिए तो आप उसको इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं
एप्ट
इंस्टॉल गोलंग कमांड से एंड उसके बाद
गोलंग का पाथ सेट आपको कर दीजिएगा अदर
वाइज आपको गोल के बिन डायरेक्टरी में जाके
उसको एग्जीक्यूट करना पड़ेगा स फाइंडर को
पाथ सेट करने के लिए सिंपल क्या करना होता
है आपको एलएस साइफन ए करेंगे
हम
सॉरी तो यहां पर आपको मिल जाएगी डॉट
प्रोफाइल डॉट प्रोफाइल आपको डरेक्ट फाइल
मिल जाएगी इसके अंदर में आप ड प्रोफाइल
मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं तो इसके अंदर में
आप ये दो जो एंट्रीज है नीचे की आप यहां
पे नीचे की एंट्रीज देख सकते हैं यहां पे
मैं यहां पे एंट्रीज दिखा देता हूं ये
वाली ये दो एंट्रीज कर दीजिएगा पहला
एंट्री जो है एक्सपोर्ट गो पाथ होम स्ल गो
एंड एक्सपोर्ट पाथ में गो पाथ स्लैश बिन
डाल दीजिएगा जो गो पाथ है उसका एंड स्लैश
बिन पे चला जाएगा एंड गो रूट जो है उसके
स्लैश बिन पे चला जाएगा पाथ में ठीक है तो
यह आप कर दीजिएगा अब यह कहां से आती है यह
आपको समझना अगर है तो मैं आपको बता देता
हूं जैसे कि अगर आपको गो का देखना है
एनवायरमेंट तो गो ई एनवी कमांड टाइप
करेंगे एंटर करेंगे तो आपको गो का
एनवायरमेंट दिख जाएगा तो इसमें आपको
दिखेगा एक गो रूट का पाथ आपको दिख जाएगा
अगर यहां पे आप देखेंगे तो गो रूट का पाथ
आपको दिखेगा जो कि यहां पे यूएसआर लिब गो
1.22 है य एंड यहां पे आपको गो पाथ दिख
जाएगा तो जो कि होम डि फ्रक्स गो है तो हम
इसी को एज अ वेरिएबल यूज कर रहे हैं एंड
यहां पे हम उसको प्रोफाइल के अंदर में
इसको डिफाइन कर रहे हैं इसका एनवायरमेंट
सेट करने के लिए
दैट्ची इको करेंगे इको करेंगे एंड यहां पे
अगर आप इसको गो पाथ को इको करेंगे तो आपको
यहां पे आ जाएगा होम डिफ स् गो उसी को
हमने डॉट प्रोफाइल में एंटर किया है उसके
बाद आप सोर्स कमांड चला के यहां पे एंड
डॉट प्रोफाइल कर दीजिएगा तो ये जो भी आपने
चेंज किया वो सेव हो जाता है तो आपका गो
एनवायरमेंट सेट हो जाएगा दैट्ची
इसको सब फाइंडर हाइन ए करके इसकी इसको
एक्सेस कर सकते हैं सब फाइंडर को आप
एक्सेस कर सकते हैं सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट चीज
सब फाइंडर से आप जब व जब आप सब डोमेंस को
फाइंड करेंगे किसी भी टारगेट के लिए वहां
पे आपको एपीआई कीज जो है ना उसको सेट करना
पड़ेगा एपीआई की अगर आप सेट किए बिना अगर
सब फाइंडर से सब डोमेन फाइंड करते हैं तो
आपको रिजल्ट्स जो है वो कम मिलेंगे और
एपीआई कीज जब एंटर कर देंगे तब आपको जो
रिजल्ट मिलेंगे वो बहुत ह्यूज रिजल्ट आपको
मिलेगा बहुत ह्यूज रिजल्ट मिलेगा लिटरल ली
बहुत यूज मिलेगा तो कैसे एपीआई की सेट
करते हैं आपको ऑलरेडी बताया हुआ है पिछले
क्लासेस में बट फिर भी एक रिकप जल्दी से
कर देता
हूं जब आप सब फाइंडर की डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
तो यहां पे आपको यह सारी सर्विसेस जो सब
फाइंडर यूज़ करता है सब डोमेन फाइंड करने
के लिए जिसमें आपको एपीआई कीज की जरूरत है
वो मिल जाएगी अब इसको आप एडिट करके इसमें
आप एपीआई कीज डाल सकते हैं यू हैव टू पुट
ऑन द एपीआई कीज इनसाइड द ब्रैकेट तो आप
यहां पे एपीआई कीज एंटर कर सकते हैं जैसे
कि जम आई का एपीआई की है हु इज एक्सएमएल
एपीआई की है वायरस टोटल एपीआई की है थ्रेड
बुक एपीआई की है शोडाउन की एपीआई की है ये
सारे एपीआई कीज आपको यूज़ करने हैं जब आप
एपीआई कीज एंटर करके जब सब डोमेन फाइंड
करेंगे तो आप ह्यूज अमाउंट ऑफ सब डोमेंस
आपको मिल जाएंगे वहां पे पहले आपको 1000
अगर सब डोमेन मिल रहा है तो एपीआई की जब
आप कंफी कर आपको 10000 यूनिक सब डोमेंस भी
मिल सकते हैं यह पावर है एपीआई की इसके
बिना एपीआई कीस के मत यूज़ कीजिएगा ठीक है
चलिए अब हम यहां पे फाइंड करते हैं इसके अ
बेसिकली अ क्या फाइंड करेंगे हम यहां पे
फाइंड करेंगे इसके सब डोमेंस को राइट तो
मैं यहां पे एलएस करूंगा एलएस करूंगा यहां
पे मैं एक
अ बेसिकली एक डायरेक्टरी बना देता हूं
एमकेडी आईआर बग कॉमर्स नाम से जिस टारगेट
के लिए हम हंट कर ें हैं तो इसी के अंदर
हम सारी चीजें जो हैं अ डालेंगे तो एम
केडीआर बिग कॉमर्स हमने कर दिया अब हम
सीडी बिग कॉमर्स में चलेंगे और इसी के
अंदर सारा काम बेसिकली हम कर रहे होंगे तो
चलिए यहां पे हमें हमारा टारगेट है bc.com
कॉपी कर लेते हैं सब फाइंडर टूल का यूज़
करते हैं एंड जस्ट वी विल ट्राई टू फाइंड
सम सब डोमेंस तो यहां पे सब फाइंडर कर
लेते हैं हान ए कर लेते हैं तो कैसे सब
डोमेन फाइंड करेंगे सब फाइंडर के बाद हान
डी देंगे डोमेन टू फाइंड द सब डोमेंस चलिए
यह कर लेंगे सोर्सेस आप स्पेसिफाई कर सकते
हैं लाइक हान s देके जो भी सोर्सेस आपको
चाहिए लाइक जो भी सोर्सेस आपको चाहिए वो
सोर्सेस आप डिफाइन कर सकते हैं ठीक है ना
उसका हान एलस करेंगे तो आप सोर्सेस भी मिल
जाएंगी देखिए सब
फाइंडर हान एलस करेंगे तो आपको जितने भी
सोर्सेस है सब फाइंडर के वो सारे सोर्सेस
मिल जाएंगे यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं ऑल द
सोर्सेस आर अवेलेबल र यूज नहीं करेंगे तो
सारे सोर्सेस आपके ये यूज करेगा कोई अगर
डिफाइन नहीं करेंगे तो आप उसके बाद यहां
पे आप नीचे आएंगे तो बाकी ऑप्शंस है यहां
पे काइंड ऑ
सब फाइंडर का अपडेट करना है तो हान अपडेट
कमांड लगा लीजिएगा उसके बाद यहां पे नीचे
की तरफ आप आएंगे तो आप रिकसिव नॉन रिकर्स
मोड जो है वो ऑन कर सकते हैं इफ यू वांट
अदर वाइज आप रहने दे सकते हैं ठीक है उसके
बाद यहां पे आप आएंगे तो थ्रेड सेट कर
सकते हैं डिफॉल्ट आपका 10 है तो स्पीड अप
करने के लिए थोड़ा बहुत आप इसको यूज कर
सकते हैं प्रॉक्सी चाहे तो प्रॉक्सी यूज
कर सकते हैं ठीक है फिलहाल के लिए अब हम
चलते हैं एंड डोमस को फाइंड करने की कोशिश
करते हैं आउटपुट अगर हम देखें यहां पे
आउटपुट के लिए तो यहां पे हान ओ यूज कर
सकते हैं टेक्स्ट फाइल में आउटपुट भी आप
सब डोमस को ले सकते हैं तो चलिए अब यहां
पे हम अपना काम शुरू कर देते हैं तो यहां
पे हम करते हैं सब फाइंडर नडी एंड यहां हम
डालते हैं bc.com bc.com के सब डोमस को
फाइंड करने की कोशिश करते हैं स्पेस करते
हैं एंड यहां पे हम न o देके हम बिग
कॉमर्स बिग कॉ txt.gz
और यहां पर हम हाइन व कर सकते हैं वर्वस
मोड के लिए ताकि आपको दिखता रहे जो भी
चीजें हो रही है यहां पे तो आप देख सकते
हैं यहां पे कि यहां पर सब डोमेन फाइंड
करना स्टार्ट हो चुका है बी कॉमर्स का एंड
वी आर गेटिंग द सब डोमेंस सो वी हैव टू
वेट फॉर द सब डोमेंस यहां पे फाइंड टोटल
फाइंड कर देगा तब तक आपको वेट करना है
एंड आपको उस टी एक्सटी फाइल में आपको व सब
डोमेन जो है वो मिल जाएगी ठीक है वी विल
वेट तो अभी जो सब डोमेन य देगा यह एपी की
विना कन्फर ए की के है आपको एपीआई की
कन्फर करनी है आपको बहुत ज्यादा सब डोमस
आपको मिलने के चांसेस है सो यर वी हैव टू
वेटल
सी हालांकि बहुत सारे सब डोमस ऑलरेडी यहां
पर हमें मिल चुका है यहां पर बहुत सब डोमस
मिले अभी तो और भी मिलेंगे य तो अभी एलियन
वल्ट से प्रोवाइड कर हैकर टारगेट से
प्रोवाइड किया इसने वी कैन
गेट मोर सब डोमेंस यर राइट सो जस्ट वेट
एंड
वच ओ
[प्रशंसा]
आप में से कोई लाइव करता है क्या लाइव कर
रहा है कोई साथ में कोई है ऐसा
जो जो लाइव कर रहा
हो आई डोंट थिंक सो कि कोई लाइव कर रहा
है थैंक यू
नईम थैंक यू सो
मच थैंक यू मिस्टर
एरर मैनेज हैकर वन से मैनेज होते हैं हैकर
वन उनको मैनेज करता
है मैने का मतलब हैकर व टीम जो है ट्रैक
टीम उसको मैनेज करती है एंड जो मैनेज नहीं
है वो डायरेक्टली प्रोग्राम मैनेज करती है
प्रोग्राम के अपना खुद ट्रैक टीम या
सिक्योरिटी टीम होती है वो मैनेज करते हैं
तो हैकर वन मैनेज वाले ज्यादा चिक चिक
करते
हैं राइट सो गेटिंग इ दर रिजल्ट्स
हियर बहुत सारे रिजल्ट्स हमें मिलेंगे
इसके थ्रू सब फाइंडर के थ्रू व विल गेट अ
लॉट ऑफ सब डोमस
हियर चलिए यहां पे कुछ एरर आ रही है
सीआरटी एसए सोर्स में क्योंकि सीआरटीएस
सोर्स जो है वो शायद एक्सेसिबल नहीं होगा
सीआरटीएस वेबसाइट शायद काम नहीं कर रही
होगी इस वजह से यह एरर आ रही है आपकी तो
यह आगे की तरफ बढ़ जाएगा दूसरे सोर्स पर
चला जाएगा तो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है इसको
इग्नोर मारते हैं
राइट ओके सो लेटस्ट वेट एंड
वच सीआरटीएस आपको दिख रहा है य डायलब
टीसीपी कनेक्शन एस्टेब्लिश नहीं हो रही है
इसका
मतलब सीआरटीएस में भी एक्सेसिबल नहीं होगा
अब यहां प हमें रिजल्ट आ चुका है 103 सब
डोमस मिले हैं बिग कॉमर्स
कॉ के यहां तो सिर्फ 103 मिले जब आपने एक
भी एपीआई की कन्फर कर दिया तो यह सब डोमेन
की जो लिस्ट है वो आपकी एगजैक्टली चेंज हो
जाएगी लिटरली चेंज हो जाएगी मैं यहां पे
चलता हूं मैं यहां पे एक वेबसाइट ओपन कर
लेता हूं वायरस
टोटल वायरस टोटल प मैं चलता हूं ठीक है आई
एम जस्ट गोइंग टू वायरस टोटल मैं य साइन
इन करता हूं लेट्स सी इफ य कैन साइन इन
विथ
भी
[संगीत]
google2 लुकअप्स पर डे आपको मिल जाता है
दैट्ची यहां पे अब मेरे को यहां पे 103 सब
डोमस मिले है ना अब मैं इस एपीआई की को
कॉन्फिन करता हूं पहले ठीक है तो मैं क्या
करूंगा व कॉमर्स
पे सब फाइंडर के उस फाइल में चलूंगा जहां
पे एए की करनी है तो विम करूंगा यहां पे
चलेंगे हम होम के
अंदर डेनिक्स के अंदर में
डॉट
कॉन्फरल के अंदर इसमें चलेंगे सब फाइंडर
के अंदर आपको प्रोवाइडर अ
कॉन्फिन चलेंगे इसको एडिट करेंगे इसको
एडिट करेंगे हमें यहां पे सिर्फ वायरस
टोटल का एपीआई की एंटर करना है तो मैं
एंटर मोड में चला जाता हूं आई मोड में एंड
यहां पे हम वायरस टोटल के एपीआई की को
हमने यहां पे इंसर्ट कर दिया है दैट्ची
सब फाइंडर बिग अब इस फाइल का नाम देते हैं
बिग कॉम वायरस टोटल क्योंकि हमने एपी
वायरस टोटल वाला डाला है तो हम यहां पे
वायरस टोटल वाली जो है वो डाल देते हैं
एंड उसके बाद हम इसको एंटर करते हैं एंड
लेट्स सी हाउ मच सब डोमेंस वी आर गेटिंग
राइट नाउ सो हम यहां पे करके हम यहां पे
एंटर करते हैं एंड लेट्स सी व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग ठीक है तो अब यहां देखिए हैकर
टारगेट आपका यूज हो रहा है सब डोमेन फाइंड
करने के लिए ग्रेट एलियन वॉल्ट आपका यूज
हो रहा है सीआरटी एसए को ये इग्नोर कर
देंगे क्योंकि सी टी एएच जो सोर्स है वो
एक्सेसिबल नहीं होगी अभी शायद अभी देखो
वायरस टोटल आ चुका है पहले वायरस टोटल
नहीं आया था 103 सब डोमेन फाइंड हुए अभी
वायरस टोटल आ चुका है ये पावर ऑफ एपीआई की
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन है अब ये वायरस टोटल को भी
यूज़ कर रहे हैं आपके सब डोमेन फाइंड करने
के लिए अभी जब एपीआई की जब आप नंबर ऑफ सब
डोमेंस देखेंगे तो आपको वो डिफरेंस नजर
आएगा पहले 103 था अभी देखते हैं कितने
है
राइट हम हम हम
सीआरटी एसए को य इग्नोर मारेगा क्योंकि
सीआरटी एस आई थिंक इट्स नॉट एक्सेसिबल सो
य कैन सी र कुछ ना कुछ इशू होगा सीआरटी एस
डोमेन में अभी फिलहाल के लिए तो या इट्स
नॉट एक्सेसिबल यू कैन नॉट एक्सेस इट ट्स
वई वी आर जस्ट इग्नो ंग दिस
सोर्स यहां पर आप देख सकते हैं वायरस टोटल
आपको डिफरेंस नजर आ रहा है नाउ वी आर
गेटिंग वायरस टोटल एपीआई की का बेनिफिट आप
देख सकते हैं व्हाट इज दिस एपीआई की
बेनिफिट
राइट आई वा रनिंग बक बाउंट फ्रॉम योर
लास्ट प्लेलिस्ट बट दिस टाइम आई विल फॉलो
एवरी डे ट्स
ग्रेट ट्स ग्रेट
हेलो फैजान ब्रो कैसे
हो
चलिए वी आर जस्ट गेटिंग द रिजल्ट्स सो वी
हैव टू वेट सीआईटी का एक वार्निंग आ सकता
है एंड देन आपको रिजल्ट्स जो है वो फाइल
के अंदर सेव मिल जाएंगे सो वी हैव टू वेट
नाउ दिस थिंग इफ यू आर डूइंग ऑन वीपीएस
अगर आप किसी क्लाउड सर्वर पे कर रहे हैं
तो ये कंपेरटिवली काफी फास्ट रिजल्ट देगा
क्योंकि हम लोकल मशीन पे कर रहे हैं तो
यहां थोड़ा टाइम लगर है जब भी वीपीएस
वगैरह प आप इसको करेंगे तो आपको
कंपेरटिवली काफी फास्ट रिजल्ट मिलेगा य आप
देख सकते हैं सोर्स सीआरटीएस का फिर से
इशू आ गया है इसको हम इग्नोर कर सकते थे
पहले ही एक्सक्लूड कर देते बेटर रहता टाइम
ज्यादा नहीं जाता बट अभी आप देखिएगा सब
डोमेन की जो लिस्ट आएगी वह देखिएगा क्या
लिस्ट आ रही है ठीक है बहुत जल्द हमें
रिजल्ट मिल जाएंगे
अब वा ल काफी सब डोमस यहां पर निकल के आया
हमारे पास अ लॉट लॉट ऑफ सबडस वी हैव गट
फ्रॉम वायरस टोटल इट विल मेक द डिफरेंस आप
देख सकते आप 103 सब डोमेन निकला था अभी
कितने सब डोमेन है यह बताओ कितने सब डोमेन
निकले सभी लोग बताइए चैट में बताइए कितने
सब डोम हमने फाइंड किया य प एक एपीआई की
मात्र कन्फर किया हमने जस्ट वन एपीआई की
एंड वी गट दिस
राइट राइट बग ओरा हाई सर आई मेक $600
फ्रॉम बाउंट ट्स ग्रेट कांग्रेचुलेशन
कितने एई कितने बताइए आप कितने सब डोमस
निकले जिसने स्क्रीन देखा होगा जो
कंसिस्टेंट हो उसको पता होगा तो चैट में
बता जल्दी बताइए फटाफट
बताइए अंजली के शॉट्स आम न्यू स्टूडेंट
वेलकम 66 तो यू कैन सी द डिफरेंस एक्चुअली
वी कैन सी द डिफरेंस कितना बड़ा फ्रेंस आ
चुका है एक एपीआई की वायरस टोटल का हमने
कन्फर किया अब इसके अलावा अगर बाकी सारे
एपीआई की कंफिल कर देंगे तो पता नहीं
कितने ही सब डोमेन वी विल फाइंड आउट तो अब
हम एलस करेंगे यहां पे जो बिग क बिग कॉम
वायरस टोटल वाली फाइल है इसमें सबसे
ज्यादा हमारे पास सब डोमस है तो बेसिकली
हम इसी को यूज करने वाले हैं बिग कॉम को
रिमूव कर देते हैं जो हमारा बिग क एकटी है
इसको हम रिमूव कर देते हैं वी आर जस्ट
रिमूविंग हमें ये नहीं चाहिए हमारा वही
वाला काफी है ठीक है तो हमारे पास आ चुकी
है अब इसको कैट करेंगे बिग कॉम वा टोटल
एंड डब्लू स हान l करेंगे तो आप देखेंगे
606 यहां पे आ गया अब हम यहां पे http1 को
यूज़ करेंगे अ जो लाइव डोमस हैं उनको
फाइंड करने के लिए तो एटीटीपी एक एक टूल
है आप अगर देखना चाहते हैं एडीपी एक के
बारे में यू कैन जस्ट सिंपली वट टू एडीपी
एक गट हब आप कर सकते हैं इसको इंस्टॉल
करना भी बहुत इजी है गो में लैंग्वेज गो
में बनी टूल है एटीपी एक को इंस्टॉल करना
है सिंपली आप यह वाला कमांड गो इंस्टॉल यह
डालिए कॉपी कीजिए एंड टर्मिनल पे अपने
पेस्ट कर दीजिए इंस्टॉल हो जाएगा दैट्ची
इंस्टॉल है यहां पे तो हम एटीटीपी एक हान
h करके इसको एक्सेस कर सकते हैं अब
एटीटीपी को एटीटीपी एक टूल को आप पाइप भी
कर सकते हैं एंड दूसरे टूल्स के साथ दूसरे
कमांड्स के साथ आप यूज भी कर सकते हैं तो
यहां पे व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू डू वी आर
गोइंग टू अप्लाई एडीपी एक ऑन द डोमेन जो
डोमेन हमें यहां पे मिला है तो अब हमें
उसका लाइव डोमेन निकालना है तो मैं यहां
पे करता हूं
कैट बग क और यहां पे हम एटीटीपी एक जो है
वो अप्लाई कर देते हैं hpx360 एंड देन हम
इस रिजल्ट को आउटपुट दे देते हैं एंड
उसमें करते हैं बिग कॉम
लाइव
txt.gz
सो एंटर करते हैं हम यहां पे एडीपी एक को
एंड देखते हैं व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग नाउ लेट्स सी
सो ल गेट द रिजल्ट्स हियर एंड ब कमला यहां
प वस मोड आप इनेबल कर देंगे तो आपको लाइव
दिखता रहेगा कि क्या चल रहा है फिलहाल
हमने इनेबल उसको नहीं किया है तो आपको
डायरेक्ट बमला जो है व एक फाइल बन जाएगी
एंड वहां पर आपको सारे यूआरएल जो है लाइव
वाले वो आपको देखने को मिल जाएंगे राइट सो
वी कैन वेट फॉर दैट
इट मे टेक टाइम डिपेंडिंग ऑन द सिस्टम
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन एंड ऑल एवरीथिंग ठीक है ना
तो आपका काम यहां पर हो चुका है अब एलस
करेंगे तो आपको मिलेगा बिक कॉम
live.com live.tv
तो अब जो है हम आरएम करके बिग कॉमर्स जो
वायरस टोटल वाली जो फाइल है उसको रिमूव कर
देते हैं अब हमारे पास एक फाइल है बग कम
लाइटी जहां पे हमारे पास लाइव डोमेन है जब
आप इसको करेंगे तो यहां पे आपको सारे
डोमेन जो है यहां पे देखने को मिल जाएंगे
बग कॉमर्स के 76 अब आप इन सब डोमेंस को
एक्सेस कर सकते हैं एंड यहां पे आप लॉगइन
फंक्शनैलिटीज वगैरह भी चेक आउट कर सकते
हैं किसमें क्या लॉगइन फंक्शनैलिटी है किस
तरीके से क्या काम करता है वो सारी चीजें
कर सकते हैं और इन पे हम हंट बेसिकली कर
सकते हैं तो बेसिकली हमारा जो मेन है यहां
पे आप देखिए wp.in vc.com यह भी है हमारा
देन आप देखेंगे यहां पे लॉग b कर्स है
यहां पे हमारे पास मैज b कर्स है यहां पे
जब आप इसको एक्सेस करने की कोशिश करेंगे
मैं यहां पे इस बार एक एक बार अ इसको ओपन
करता हूं man.com
तो यहां पे ओपन हो चुका है ऑलरेडी यहां पे
आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे कि यहां पे लॉग
इन टू योर स्टोर करके आ रहा है यहां पे
साइन अप करने का ऑप्शन आ रहा है
दैट्ची लॉगइन प करते हैं यहां
पे तो यह यूआरएल एजिस्ट नहीं करता है नॉट
फाउंड आ रहा है कोई बात नहीं कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है देन व विल सी शॉप डॉट ब कमर्स अगर
यहां पर कोई पैनल वगैरह एजिस्ट करता है तो
यहां प आप शॉप डॉट पे आ चुके हैं राइट सो
इस तरीके से हमें सब डोमेन हमने फाइंड कर
लिया है ऑलरेडी अब यहां पर सब डोमेन जब
फाइंड कर लिया लाइव सब डोमेन निकाल लिए अब
हम एक और तरीका देखेंगे एक और अप्रोच
देखेंगे वो अप्रोच है
डॉकी में जब जाएंगे तो एक टूल आती है डॉकर
टूल आता है यहां पर फ्री आपको मिलेगा सर्च
इंजन डॉकर यहां प तो आपको यहां प बेसिकली
टारगेट डिफाइन करनी है यहां प आपको टारगेट
देना है तो जो भी टारगेट आपको देना है ब
कॉमर्स का देना है इसके कोई सब डोमेन है
उसको देना है उसका देना है वो आप यहां पर
डिफाइन कर सकते हैं जैसे मेरा कोई एक मेरा
इसमें कोई एक सब डोमेन है मान लो मेरा जो
सब डोमेन है वो इंटरेस्टिंग सब डोमेन क्या
है चलिए एपीआई बी कॉमर्स प क्या
है 404 है ठीक है कोई बात नहीं
सीडीएन बिकॉमर्स डीएनएस सेरर इज गेटिंग
ठीक
है लेट्स सी दिस वन नॉट फाउंड
ओके इवेंटस डेव टूल ईमेल बी कमर्स आइडिया
फ्रंट सीडी एन पायलट इसको देख लेते हैं
यहां पर इ देर सम काइंड ऑफ लॉगइन
फंक्शनालिस
अन अवेलेबल है यह साइट फिलहाल के लिए कोई
बात नहीं य पे
देख लेते हैं मे बी दे सम काइंड ऑफ लॉगइन
न नो नो नो पैनल तो यहां पर हमारे पास एक
है यहां पर जो पैनल है लॉगिन वाली वो
लॉगिन पैनल को हम एक्सेस कर लेते राइट सो
द पैनल व गट
यर अकाउट ब कमस
कॉ लॉगिन प आप रीडायरेक्ट हो चुके तो यहां
पे एक मिल चुका है आपके पास एक पैनल मिल
चुका है login.com . कॉ तो आप इस पे भी
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं मेन वेबसाइट प भी
कर सकते हैं तो मान लो मेरा मेन डोमेन है
bc.com
मैं bc.com करता हूं डक टूल पे चलता हूं
यहां पे यहां पे डाल देता हूं bc.com अब
यहां
टोकन कैन बी प्रेजेंट एनी वेयर जरूरी नहीं
है कि आप लॉगइन करके उसको अ जब आप करेंगे
लॉगइन करेंगे जब आप उसको इंटरसेप्ट करेंगे
वहां पे आपको मिलेगा ऐसा नहीं है आप किसी
फाइल के अंदर भी आपको टोकेंस मिल जाएगा तो
वी कैन ट्राई ऑल द पॉसिबिलिटीज व्हाट वी
कैन राइट तो यहां पे आप डेटाबेस फाइल से
एक्सेल फाइल से s3 बकेट है यहां पे ओपन
डायरेक्शन एक्सेस डॉक्स ये सब हमारे काम
कर नहीं है लॉगिन पेजेस ये हमारे काम का
हो सकता है तो लॉगिन पेजेस प जाएंगे तो
यहां पे डॉक्स जो है आपके यहां पे आ चुके
हैं सारे डॉक्स तो मैं एक काम करता हूं
मैं बाकी जो यहां
पे यूआरएल है उनको फिलहाल के लिए क्लोज कर
देता हूं दे जस्ट क्लोजिंग दज यूआरएल
राइट ठीक
है अब यहां पे लॉगइन का ऑप्शन आ रहा है
सर्च करेंगे तो यहां पे आपको
बट हमारे कोई
रिजल्ट कुछ नहीं मिला यहां सर्च करते हैं
इफ वी कैन गेट सम रिजल्ट्स नो
रिजल्ट्स सारे डॉक को यूज कर
लेंगे यू कैन जस्ट कीप इट ओपन इन डिफरेंट
काइंड ऑफ
टैब्स सो यहां टैब ओपन करते हैं
जस्ट जितने टैब्स आप ओपन कर सकते हैं ना
यू कैन जस्ट ओपन इट एंड सी द रिजल्ट्स ठीक
है यहां पे रिजल्ट्स में यहां पर कुछ हमें
रिजल्ट्स मिले हैं इसका ट्स ग्रेट यहां भी
हमें रिजल्ट कुछ मिले हैं बहुत बढ़िया
यहां भी हमें
कुछ रिजल्ट्स मिले हैं नो रिजल्ट्स क्लोज
करते नो रिजल्ट नो रिजल्ट्स नो रिजल्ट्स
नो रिजल्ट्स नो
रिजल्ट्स नो रिजल्ट्स नो रिजल्ट नो
रिजल्ट्स नो रिजल्ट्स नो रिजल्ट्स नो
रिजल्ट्स यहां भी कुछ रिजल्ट हमें मिले
हैं यहां यहां भी रिजल्ट मिले हैं तो इसको
रहन देते हैं नो रिजल्ट्स वाले जितने भी
नो रिजल्ट्स है उनको क्लोज कर देंगे हमारे
किसी काम का नहीं है यहां कुछ मिला है
क्या नो
नथिंग नथिंग
नथिंग यहां कुछ रिजल्ट्स है ठीक है अब हम
रिजल्ट्स को एनालाइज करेंगे फॉर लॉगिन
सेक्शन जो भी लॉगिन लॉगिन पेजेस है जहां
पर हम जेडब्ल्यू टोकन फाइंड करने की कोशिश
कर सकते हैं राइट तो यहां पर एक लॉगइन ब
कर्स कॉ आया है अच्छी बात
है यह था आई थिंक वही वाली पेज है ग्रेट
यहां पे लॉगिन बिग कॉमर्स सपोर्ट लॉगइन है
यहां पे लेट्स सी व्ट दिस टाइप ऑफ लॉगिन
इज यह सेम लॉगिन है या कुछ और
है सो दिस इज सम काइंड ऑफ डिफरेंट
लॉगिन तो आप यहां पर भी लॉगइन देख सकते
हैं यहां पर एक लॉगइन आप आएंगे यहां पर
लॉगिन पर क्लिक करते हैं यहां प ठीक है तो
ब कमर्स स्टोर लॉगिन है एक यहां पे अच्छी
बात है यहां पे फॉरगेट साइन अप कर सकते
हैं स्टोर लॉगिन दूसरी जो लॉगिन है यहां
पे ददर लॉग इन इस पार्टनर लॉगिन तो यहां
पर पार्टनर पोर्टल लॉगिन भी है तो यह
अच्छी बात है कम्युनिटी अकाउंट से कर सकते
लॉगिन पार्टनर पोर्टल पार्टनर पोर्टल को
देखते हैं क्या है य पाटनर bc.com प आपका
लॉगइन जाता है
ये ट्स ग्रेट यहां पे यहां प आप देख सकते
हैं साइन इन यहां पे आप पार्टनर कर सकते
हैं यहां पे साइन इन प जाके एंड यू कैन
नॉट अ बिकम तो अप्लाई आप करके यहां प
पार्टनर लॉगइन है तो बेसिकली वी कैन जस्ट
ट्राई आउट द हेडर पार्ट हेडर को हम देख
सकते हैं क्या है कुछ तो यहां पे सपोर्ट
वाली अगेन लॉगइन आ रही है यहां
पे कस्टमर लॉगिन एस कस्टमर लिंक यहां पर
क्या है ये इसको देख लेते हैं
सेम द सेम लॉगिन पेज य यहां पर डेवलपमेंट
डेव सेंटर जो है और डेवलपर सेंटर है आपका
यहां पर भी आपका लॉगिन का यहां पर आपको
आएगा अब यहां पर आप दे अब देखो यहां पे जब
हम यहां देख रहे हैं लॉगइन टोकन में आप
देख सकते हैं योर स्टोर एग्जांपल लॉगिन
टोकन जेडब्ल्यू टोकन सो जेडब्ल्यू यूज हो
रहा है गाइस व आर यूजिंग हियर वी कैन सी
हियर कि
व द लॉगिन डेवलपर आप जब एपीआई गाइड प आप
आएंगे तो यहां प आप देखेंगे जेडब्ल्यू
टोकन दे आर यूजिंग एंड इट्स इंटरेस्टिंग
ये इंटरेस्टिंग हो सकता है किसी तरह का
कोई कॉन्फिन हो कुछ हो तो मजा आ जाएगा
राइट तो हम इसको लाइव देखेंगे अभी अभी अभी
आएगा मजा अभी आएगा शानदार वाला मजा मजा
मजा अभी तो आपको ही मजा आ गया जेडब्ल्यूडी
चल रहा है
भाई जेडब्ल्यूडी चल रहा है इट्स अ न्यू
इट्स अ न्यू सेशन
इमरान चलिए ये अच्छी बात
है यह एक मिल ग हमें कस्टमर एपीआई है यहां
पे वन क्लिक सोशल लॉगिंग इंटीग्रेशन है
यहां पे कस्टमर लॉगिन एपीआई है यहां पे
ठीक है तो यहां से हमें कुछ रिजल्ट्स मिल
चुके हैं नाउ दूसरे साइट प चलते हैं यहां
पे डिसेबल लॉगिन एंड यूजर ये कुछ नहीं है
यहां रिफ्रेश चेक आउट लॉगइन यहां पे कुछ
नहीं है हाउ टू यह भी कुछ नहीं है
खास यहां पे आई हैव इंस्टॉल वर्डप्रेस
साइट चेंज लॉग है यहां पेड चेक आउट बेट
चेक आउट चेंज लॉग है
नॉट ब कमर्स आ रिटर्न इंटीग्रेशन है बिक
कॉमर्स इंटीग्रेशन है य पर स्टिंग प्रो
इंटीग्रेशन
है नथिंग नथिंग नथि नथिंग
देर कम ं कुछ खास नहीं य पर यहां देख लेते
पासवर्ड पासवर्ड लेस्ट कस्टमर लॉगिन य तो
डे सेंटर है तो वहा पर आपको वो मिलेंगे
बाकी हमें कुछ यहां पर कुछ खास नहीं है
लॉगिन टू योर स्टोर वाला ऑप्शन है तो यह
तो है यहां पर तो यहां पर आप देख सकते हैं
यह पास य तो इनका गाइड है
राइट नाउ अब जो है यहां पर पार्टनर लॉगिन
भी हम ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं व कैन जस्ट
ट्राई आउट द पार्टनर लॉगइन पेज टू तो
पार्टनर लॉगइन पेज भी य पे जो बना हुआ है
पार्टनर वाली तो यहां पर जब आप लॉगिन प
जाएंगे तो एक और लॉगिन पेज हमें मिला
था यह वाली राइट य लॉगिन पेज यहां पे मिली
है एंड एजेंसी अफिट पार्टनर्स एंड ये सारे
पार्टनर जो है यहां पर मिले है तो चलिए
अभी हम एक काम कर देते हैं व्हाट वी आर
गोइंग टू डू वी आर गोइंग टू लॉग इन हियर
लॉग इन करने की एंड साइन अप हियर यह सब
चीजें करते हैं चलिए तो अब जो है यहां पे
हम चलते हैं बॉब सूट के ऊपर चलेंगे बॉब
सूट के ऊपर चलके एंड वी विल ट्राई टू
फाइंड आउट राइट कि लॉगइन करने के बाद हमें
क्या-क्या फंक्शनालिस किस तरीके की चीजें
मिलती है तो मैं इस पेज को यहां पर कॉपी
कर लेता
हूं एंड यहां पे पेस्ट कर कर देता
हूं ठीक है सो वी गट इट
यर ओके अब यहां पे हम साइन अप कर लेते हैं
पहले फर्स्ट वी विल जस्ट साइन अप तो साइन
अप करने के बाद आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे
फर्स्ट नेम लास्ट नेम फोन नंबर ईमेल आईडी
ये सारी चीजें दे दे रख आपको देनी है तो
मैं य फर्स्ट नेम दे देता हूं यहां पे
फर्स्ट नेम यहां प दे देते हैं मिस्टर
परफेक्ट फोन नंबर यहां फोन नंबर भी देना
है द थिंग इज दैट कि फोन नंबर यू हैव टू
प्रोवाइड सो मैं य पर फोन नंबर दे देता
हूं ओके इंटरनेशनल कोड चाहिए इनको तो प्लस
91 दे देते हैं ईमेल एड्रेस देना है य तो
ईमेल एड्रेस जो है मैं
नितेश सिं
हैकर gmail.com देता हूं पासवर्ड देना है
य
पे तो मैंने पासवर्ड दे दिया एटलीस्ट 12
कैरेक्टर होना चाहिए ठीक
है तो पासवर्ड दे दिया हमने स्टोर नेम
स्टोर नेम डालते हैं यहां पर तो स्टोर नेम
यहां पर डाल देते हैं
परफेक्ट स्टोर व्ट इज द साइज ऑफ योर
ऑनलाइन बिजनेस आईव नॉट स्टार्टड से नो
रेवेन्यू ए यहां पर होस्टेड एट एशिया
पैसिफिक ट्स इट ठीक है तो एवरीथिंग इज डन
यहां पे अब यहां पर हम क्रिएट योर स्टोर
पर क्लिक कर देते हैं यहां पर नेवर कर
देते हैं यहां पे य स्टोर विल बी रेडी इन
मिनट ट्स वेरी गुड
थिंग तो वी हैव टू वेट फॉर द स्टोर
राइट
ओके स्टोर को रेडी हो जाने देते हैं देन
हम लॉग इन करेंगे देन देखते हैं स्टार्ट
योर ट्रायल ओ यह ट्रायल वर्जन स्टार्ट
करवाएगा क्या क्या करवा रहे भैया चलिए कोई
बात नहीं देख लेते हैं ट इस
हैपनिंग स्टार्ट यो फ्री 15 डे ट्राल नो
क्रेडिट कार्ड रिक्वायर्ड य अच्छी बात है
कि क्रेडिट कार्ड नहीं चाहिए ये एक लंबा
प्रोसेस फिर से हो जाता सो लेट्स
वेट इनका और भी एक लॉगिन पैनल था लॉगिन
पेजेस और भी थे इनके तो अगर मैं लॉगिन
पेजेस सर्च करूं यह यह
यह तो कुछ लॉगिन पेजेस हमें मिले थे
पार्टनर लॉगिन पेज हमें कुछ मिला था
शायद कोई बात नहीं फिलहाल के लिए हम यहां
पर या स्टोर जज रेडी हाउ डू यू हैव एन
एस्टिंग वेबसाइट नो व्ट विल बी सेलिंग तो
मैं यहां पर ल देता हूं डिजिटल गुड्स एंड
सॉफ्टवेयर्स व्ट बेस्ट डिस्क्राइब करंट
तोली पर्सन और इन रिटेल स्टोर थ ऑनलाइन
आईम सेल मेनली थ्रू ऑनलाइन प्रोसीड टू
स्टोर ठीक है तो स्टोर में प्रोसीड कर
देते
हैं चलिए तो स्टोर पे हम आ चुके हैं वी
हैव जस्ट एक्सेस द स्टोर हियर ट्स ग्रेट
एंड आप यहां पे आ चुके हैं अब यहां पे मैं
क्या कर देता हूं प्रोफाइल प चलता हूं
यहां पे लॉग आउट प क्लिक कर देता
हूं लॉग आउट कर दिया हमने अब हम इसको लॉग
इन करेंगे एंड वी विल जस्ट सी व्हाट वी
कैन डू हियर चलिए
तो यहां पर ईमेल आईडी डालता हूं नितेश सिं
हैकर gmail.com पासवर्ड डाल देते
हैं जो हमने पासवर्ड दिया था बप को इनेबल
कर देते हैं ब प्रॉक्सी इनेबल कर देते हैं
बब शूट को ऑन कर देते हैं जेडब्ल्यू एडिटर
के साथ में सो लेट्स स्विच न ब नेक्स्ट
नेक्स्ट स्टार्ट एंड ट्स इट ठीक
है स् को मॉनिटर करेंगे हम इसके
डन जेडब्ल्यू एडिटर इज लोडेड प्रॉक्सी एडी
ी प चल लेते हैं एंड नाउ वल जस्ट लॉग इन
यहां पर लॉग इन करेंगे और ल लॉग इन इन टू
द स्टोर हियर लेट्स सी इफ वी कैन गेट सम
समथिंग तोहा पे लॉगइन हो चुके हैं जब य ए
हिस्ट्री प जाएंगे तो हमें यहां पे देखने
को मिलेगा जेडब्ल्यूडी यहां पर आपको
जेडब्ल्यू मिल रहा है इंक्रिप्शन
इंक्रिप्शन इंक्रिप्टेड है यहां पे आपका
देख सकते हैं यहां पे जेसन वेब टोकन जो है
वो इनक्रिप्टेड मिल रहे हैं और यहां पे जो
एक है इंटरनल एपीआई करके जो है न जेडटी है
यह इंक्रिप्टेड नहीं है यह वेब टोकन हैं
यह एक अच्छी चीज मिली हमें 200 मिल रहा है
पैरामीटर्स नहीं है वो अलग बात है बट या
वी गॉट इट र राइट गॉट समथिंग हमें
वन जेडब्ल्यू टी अगर मिलता है तो
दैट्ची स्लोर इट
राइट
चलिए हम देखते हैं कि हम इसमें क्या कर
सकते हैं व्हाट वी कैन स्टिल डू आप देख
सकते हैं य पे जेडब्ल्यू के टोकन हमें
मिले हैं राइट यू कैन सी राइट कि वी गट द
जेडब्ल्यू
टोकन देखा
आपने आपको आप सबको दिखा य जेडब्ल्यू टोकन
मिला है तो एवरीवन कैन सी जेडब्ल्यू टोकन
हम हमें रिजल्ट्स में मिले हैं हमें राइट
तो आप देख सकते हैं इस चीज को
यस राइट राइट गुड तो अब हम चलते हैं एंड
फॉर जेडब्ल्यूडी यहां 200 जो मिला यह बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग लग रहा है मुझे पैरामीटर्स
नहीं है बट ठीक है वी हैव द जेडब्ल्यूडी
टोकन राइट गाइस तो एक काम करते हैं एडमिन
थ जो है यहां प 302 है नॉट सेइंग एनीथिंग
यहां पे है अकाउंट लॉगइन का कुछ मिला है
क्या य
रिमोट एडमिन कुछ मिला य पर कंट्रोल पैनल
स्टोर टोकन यहां पर एक मिला है एडमिन
सर्विसेस यहां पर डब् एनक्रिप्टेड यहां पर
आ रहे हैं
सारे एक काम करते हैं सबसे पहले हम यहां
पर वन ज
डब्ल्यूटीपी आई कंट्रोल पैनल करके जो यहां
पर आ रहा है आपका तो इस पर चलते
हैं इस पर्टिकुलर को सेंड टू रिपीटर सेंड
टू रिपीटर प जाते हैं एंड यहां पे हम इसको
रेस्प इसके रिस्पांस को देखते हैं 200 ओके
आ रहा
है ट्स ग्रेट इफ वी गेट सम काइंड
ऑफ लाइक जेडब्ल्यू डिटेल्स यहां पे तो
हमें यहां पे जेसन डिटेल्स तो हमें नहीं
मिले यहां पे कुकीज में यहां पे जेडब्ल्यू
टोकन जो है यहां पे सेशन टोकन आपको मिल
रहा है राइट सो हियर यू कैन सी द टू
डॉट्स जो मिला है तो सेकंड जो डॉट है
पेलोड में कुछ अगर मिलता हमें तो कुछ खास
हमें तो यहां पर देखने को मिल नहीं रहा है
व्ट इज दिस
थिंग यह वाला आपका यह पेलोड आपका यह देखते
हैं य पे सो इफ यू कैन सी
यर नथिंग वी आर गेटिंग
हियर ओके सो वी आर नॉट फाइंडिंग एनीथिंग
जस्ट कॉपी इट
ओके कुछ खास तो यहां पर हमें देखने को मिल
रहा नहीं रहा है
राइट सो दिस वन एंड दिस वन सोम टोकन यहां
पर सेशन टोकन आपको एक मिल रही है इस
पर्टिकुलर सेशन टोकन यहां पर कुछ इस तर
सेशन टोकन आपको मिल रहा है हमारा कुछ खास
काम का नहीं है यहां पर यहां पर हम चलते
हैं एंड लेट्स सी इफ यू कैन सी दिस वन कॉल
बैक यहां पे या मैनेज वाले पे चलते हैं तो
मैनेज में कॉल बैक या कॉल बैक में हम कर
सकते हैं इंटरनल एपीआई नोटिफिकेशन एडमिन
सर्विस यहां पे वन जडब्ल्यू मिल रही है तो
इसको भी हम एक बार ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं
सो लेट्स गिव इट अ ट्राई सेंड टू
रिपीटर तो यहां पे हमारे पास आ चुका है हम
यहां पे रिस्पांस देखते हैं इसका रिस्पांस
क्या आता है 200 ओ के रिस्पांस में हमें
रिजल्ट्स यहां पे आ रहे हैं रिजल्ट्स में
यहां पे आपका आ रहा है नेम आ रहा है आईडी
यहां पे आपकी आ रही है वन नेम आ रहा है
प्लेटफॉर्म आ रहा है ए यहां पर आप देखेंगे
कि एक्सटर्नल आईडी आपको एक यहां पे जो कि
कुछ डिफाइन नहीं है यहां पे यूआरएल का
आइकन का यूआरएल आ रहा है उसके बाद ज्यादा
कुछ खास हमारे पास चीजें आ नहीं रही है
राइट
बट बट यहां पे हमें टोकन मिला है आप देख
सकते हैं यहां पे जसन वेब टोकन हमें मिले
हैं यहां पे यह टोकन मिला है तो यहां से
यह एंड होता है यहां पे एंड यहां से यह जो
है आपकी स्टार्ट हो रही है एंड दिस इज द
सिग्नेचर तो आपको सिग्नेचर भी यहां पर मिल
रहा है तो व्हाट वी कैन डू हियर तो मैं
यहां पे एक बार पलट को कॉपी कर लेता
हूं इफ वयी कैन सी एनीथिंग यूआरएल इनकोडेड
है यहां पे इफ यू कैन सी द यूआरएल
इनकोडिंग पार्ट इज देयर राइट यूआरएल
इनकोडिंग आपको मिल रही है उसके बाद अगर हम
देखेंगे
इसका फर्स्ट पार्ट टोकन के बारे में बताता
है जो कि तो बेस 64 इनकोडिंग मिली है यहां
पे एंड यहां पे अ एल्गोरिथम डीआर एंड
इंक्रिप्शन जो है यह आपका hs256 यूज़ हो
रहा है इस पर्टिकुलर सस के अंदर में तो
इसको हम बेस 64 से डिकोड करके हम यहां पर
लेक आ य बेस 64 इनकोडिंग यहां पर यूज हो
रही है फिलहाल के लिए तो अगर मैं इसको
बेसिकली यहां प जब डिकोड करके आप लाए हैं
तो यहां पर डिकोड करके यहां प आ रही है
एलजी डायरेक्टरी इंक्रिप्शन आपका इस तरीके
से पेलोड के बारे में बता रहा है उसके बाद
यहां से हम पेलोड को चूज अगर कर लेते
हैं सी द पेलोड
सो दिस पर्टिकुलर थिंग इज कमिंग राइट दिस
पर्टिकुलर थिंग कैन बी एनीथिंग यल
इनकोडिंग या कुछ भी यहां पर यूआरएल कोडिंग
हो रही है तो मैं यहां पे इस पर्टिकुलर
चीज को यूआरएल डिकोड करके देख सकते
हैं यूआरएल
डिकोड आप इसको बप में भी कर सकते हैं तो
मैं यहां पे यह करता हूं मैं यहां डिकोड
करता हूं लेट्स सी इफ वी गेट
समथिंग सो वी आर नॉट गेटिंग एनीथिंग काइंड
ऑफ राइट बब के डिकोडर पे चल लेते हैं यहां
पे डिकोडर पे चल लेते बब के यहां पे डिकोड
एज
यूआरएल
नो इफ वयी कैन सी
लाइक रिपीटर पे चलते हैं सो यहां पे हमें
कुछ रिजल्ट्स आए हैं एंड दिस रिजल्ट्स आर
इंक्रिप्ट ओबवियसली इंक्रिप्टेड यहां पे
आपका जो पब्लिक स्टोर चैनल्स आ रहा है सो
अब एक बार प्रॉक्सी प चलते हैं एंड हमारा
जो पब्लिक स्टोर वाला जो है अब दूसरे किसी
एक पर्टिकुलर य यू को देखते हैं ठीक है तो
हमारे पास था एडमिन सर्विसेस हमने देखा था
यह वाला इसके अलावा वी कैन फाइंड आउट
डिफरेंट अदर डिफरेंट सर्विसेस साइट्स यहां
पे देख सकते हैं जेडटी या देर इज बट नॉट
यूजफुल इसमें चलते कुछ यूजफुल हमें कुछ
मिल जाता है तो नो यूज कोई यूजफुल नहीं
यहां पे हमारे लिए कोई यूजफुल नहीं है यह
इसमें देखते हैं टोकन क्या है यहां पर
यूय आईडी आ रही है बट यहां पर हमारे पास
टोकन में कुछ खास यहां पर हमें देखने को
मिल रही है मैनेज प चलते हैं यहां पे सी
दैट नो पर्टिकुलर हमारे लिए कोई
खास टोकन तो यहां पर नहीं एक सेशन टोकन आ
रहा है जो यहां पर आपको मिल रही है दिस
सेशन टोकन कैन बी इंक्रिप्टेड फॉर्म कोई
सा भी फॉर्म आपका इंक्रिप्ट आप इसको जब
कॉपी करेंगे यहां पर तो यहां पे आप
देखेंगे कि कुछ इस तरह का टेक्स्ट है यहां
पे कोई डिस्क्रिप्शन यहां पे आपको देखने
को नहीं मिल रही है
बेसिकली यहां देखेंगे तो किसी तरह का कोई
डिस्क्रिप्शन आपको देखने को नहीं मिल रहा
है तो इट्स नॉट यूज़फुल फॉर अस सो यहां पे
चलते हैं यहां पे भी कुछ खास यूज़फुल है
नहीं यहां पे एडमिन आईसी इस पे चलते हैं
एंड इफ यू कैन सी इफ वी कैन गेट सम काइंड
ऑफ डिटेल्स हियर सो
नथिंग ऑन बोर्डिंग में चलते हैं यहां पे
ऑन बोर्डिंग में यहां पे देख लेते हैं ना
कुछ खास यहां पे हम नहीं मिल रहा है सो
यहां तो कुछ खास हमें नहीं मिला है जब बात
करते हैं उसकी तो हम एक काम कर सकते हैं
व्ट वी कैन डू सो वन हम इसको लॉग आउट कर
लेते हैं हम इसको क्या करेंगे वी आर जस्ट
प्रोफाइल पर जाके इसको लॉग आउट करते हैं
राइट नाउ वल इंटरसेप्ट इट अब हम यहां पर
इंटरसेप्ट करेंगे तो इंटरसेप्ट प चलते हैं
यहां चलते हैं ईमेल आईडी डालते हैं
नितेश
सिंकर gmail.com ए य पासवर्ड हमने जो सेट
किया
था तो यह डाला हमने अब हम इसको इंटरसेप्ट
करेंगे इंटरसेप्ट ऑन किया मैंने एंड
इंटरसेप्ट लॉगिन करते हैं इंटरसेप्ट करते
हैं यहां पे जब इंटरसेप्ट कर रहे हैं हम
यहां पे तो ये लॉगिन इंटरसेप्शन आपकी इस
तरीके से आ रही है राइट तो नाउ व्हाट वी
आर गोइंग टू
डू यहां पे मैं इंटरसेप्ट कर रहा हूं तो
आप यहां प देख सकते हैं मैं इसका राइट
क्लिक करता हूं डू इंटरसेप्ट रिस्पांस टू
दिस रिक्वेस्ट तो हम भी इंटरसेप्ट करेंगे
यहां पे यहां प देखेंगे ऑथेंटिसिटी टोकन
आपको एक टोकन यहां पे ऑथेंटिसिटी टोकन मिल
रही है दिस इज नॉट बट
आवर काइंड ऑफ वो तो यहां पर हमें मिल चुकी
है अब यहां पे हम फॉरवर्ड करते हैं इसके
रिस्पांस को देखते हैं फॉरवर्ड करते यह
रहा रिस्पांस यहां पे यह रिस्पांस आपको
मिल चुका है यहां पे सो वी विल जस्ट पुट
आउट द रिस्पांस हियर यहां रिस्पांस
देखेंगे तो 302 फाउंड आ रहा है यहां पे
रीडायरेक्शन फॉलो करना पड़ेगा हमें आई
थिंक एंड यहां हम किसी तरह का कोई टोकन
जेडब्ल्यूडी का कुछ हमें मिल नहीं रहा है
सो ठीक है मैं यहां पर रिस्पांस में ओके
सो लेट्स
फॉरवर्ड यहां पर रिक्वेस्ट आ यहां पर
फॉरवर्ड करते
हैं नाउ हेयर इज
द कुकी में आप देखते हैं अगर कोई टोकन
आपको मिल जाता है ल ट्राई टू फाइंड आउट द
टोकन डू इंटरसेप्ट रिस्पांस फॉरवर्ड कर
देते हैं इसको
यह रिस्पांस आ गई आपकी 302 फाउंड अगेन
यहां पर
एंड
फॉरवर्ड इसको भी रिस्पांस को करते हैं
यहां पर आपको रिस्पांस एक आया है टू फ
फॉरवर्ड यहां पर आपको यहां से भी कुछ खास
यहां पर हमें कुछ मिल नहीं रहा वी आर नॉट
फाइंडिंग
समथिंग इंटरेस्टिंग
सो वी विल जस्ट फॉरवर्ड इट फॉरवर्ड इट
फॉरवर्ड इट नथिंग वी गट नथिंग एक तरह से
देखा जाए तो कुछ खास नहीं यहां पे यहां पे
एक स्टोर एडमिन का यहां पर रिस्पांस करके
देख लेते हैं इफ वी कैन गेट समथिंग तो वी
कैन
जस्ट य जस्ट फॉरवर्डिंग य पे यहां पर आपको
यहां पर आपको 302 फाउंड मिला है 302 मिला
है यहां पे एंड र नॉट जस्ट वी आर जस्ट
फॉरवर्डिंग इट रिक्वेस्ट इज देयर थ
रिक्वेस्ट इज देयर वी कैन एक्सेप्ट यू कैन
जस्ट इंटरसेप्ट इसको भी हम इंटरसेप्ट करके
रिस्पांस को देख सकते हैं इफ वी कैन गेट
समथिंग राइट कोई टोकन हमें अगर कुछ मिल
जाता है वी कैन जस्ट ट्राई टू फाइंड द
टोकन यहां कुछ खास टोकन हमें नहीं मिली है
यहां पे हमारे पास एडमिन कॉल बैक यहां पे
है इसको भी इंटरसेप्ट करके देख सकते हैं
हर रिक्वेस्ट को आपको एक्सेप्ट करना है हर
रिक्वेस्ट को आपको कैप्चर करना है एंड
जस्ट ट्राई टू गेट द रिजल्ट्स राइट
जेसन वेब टोकन पे चलते हैं यहां पे जेसन
वेब टोकन आपको दिख रहा है यहां पे वी हैव
गॉट सम जेसन वेब टोकन 302 पे यहां जसन वेब
टोकन मिले हैं यहां पे एल्गोरिदम जो है
डीआई आर आपका यूज हो रहा है यहां पे
इंक्रिप्शन यहां पे यूज हो रही है
इंक्रिप्टेड की कुछ खास यहां पे आपको यूज
हो नहीं रहा है तो व्हाट वी कैन डू यहां
पे इसको हम राइट क्लिक करके सेंड टू
रिपीटर करते हैं रिपीटर पे सेंड कर देते
हैं एंड रिपीटर पे चलते हैं यहां पे एंड
यहां पे हम देखेंगे एडमिन औरथ कॉन्फिन
यहां पे हमें क्या रिजल्ट्स मिल रहे हैं
हमें रिजल्ट्स देखना है यहां पे व विल
जस्ट ट्राई टू फाइंड द रिजल्ट्स सेंड करते
हैं हम यहां पे तो मैं यहां पे 302 फाउंड
मिला फॉलो रीडायरेक्शन फॉलो कर लेते हैं
एक बार तो 505 एडी वर्जन नॉट सपोर्टेड आ
रहा है यहां पे सो इट्स नॉट सपोर्टेड राइट
सो इट्स नॉट ऑफ आर यूज काइंड ऑफ फिलहाल के
लिए चलिए प्रॉक्सी पे चलते हैं यहां पे
एंड यहां पे हम अ क्या कर सकते हैं वी कैन
जस्ट ट्राई आउट
देखते हैं कुछ अगर पॉसिबल हो पाता है यहां
पर डीआई एल्गोरिदम है यहां
पे यहां पर एल्गोरिदम को अगर मान लो लेट्स
सपोज इफ वी कैन जस्ट चेंज इ टू नन एंड
चेंज द वैल्यूज तो ये जड ई है यहां पे
यहां पे आप नीचे आएंगे तो कोई वैल्यू
डिफाइन करनी पड़ेगी बट यहां पे वी आर नॉट
गेटिंग एनी काइंड ऑफ वैल्यू बिकॉज इट्स अ
हेडर वैल्यू तो यहां पे हमें कोई वैल्यू
नहीं मिल रही है तो इस वजह से हम इसको
जस्ट फॉरवर्ड कर देते हैं य जस्ट फॉरवर्ड
इट जस्ट फॉरवर्ड इट फॉरवर्ड इट फॉरवर्ड
यहां फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड
यहां फॉरवर्ड किया यहां पे एक रिक्वेस्ट
मिली है अ जस्ट जिस इस रिक्वेस्ट को हम
बेसिकली फॉरवर्ड इंटरसेप्ट कर सकते हैं
जेडब्ल्यू टी रिक्वेस्ट है ये इस
रिक्वेस्ट प आप आएंगे तो यहां
पे फॉरवर्ड करते
हैं या सो वी गट द जेसन वेब टोकन यहां पे
जेसन वेब टोकन में ये फिर से जेड जे डब्
आई है यहां पे इस ब एल्गोरिदम इ डीआई आर
एंड क्रिप्शन की इज दिस पर्टिकुलर थिंग
एंड यहां पर आप बेसिकली जो है आपको यहां
पर डिटेल्स मिल जाएंगी जो भी डिटेल्स है
अगर आपको कुछ मिलता है साइनिंग का या कुछ
ऐसा यहां पर कुछ डाटा मिलना चाहिए आपको
पेलोड का है तो आपको पेलोड आप चेक करना
पड़ेगा आपको कि किस टाइप की पेलोड है सो
लेट्स कॉपी दिस वन हेडर वैल्यू को हम कॉपी
करते हैं तो अगेन यहीं पर हेडर वैल्यू जो
है वो आ रही है एंड पेलोड इज काइंड ऑफ
इंक्रिप्टेड
सो इट्स यूआरएल इनकोडिंग यर कोडिंग यहां
पर की गई यहां पे सो नथिंग इज
देयर दिस पर्टिकुलर थिंग वी कैन जस्ट कीप
इट यहां पे कॉपी कर सकते हैं यहां पे यहां
पर आप डिकोडर प ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं इफ
वी कैन गेट समथिंग लाइक डिकोड एज यूआरएल
डिकोड प कुछ अगर मिल जाता है हमें तो कुछ
खास हमें मिलता नहीं यहां पर कुछ मिल नहीं
रहा है इफ वी कैन सी इफ वी कैन सी डिकोड
एस डिकोड
ओके यहां पर हमने इसको कॉपी किया ट क्लिक
किया यूआरएल डिकोड करते हैं लेट्स सी इफ
वी कैन फाइंड समथिंग सो नो नो नथिंग इ
देयर सो इसको फॉरवर्ड हम कर
लेंगे तो टोकन फाइंड करना एंड देन टोकन के
ऊपर एक्ट करना इ
रियली आपके स्किल के ऊपर यूज में आएगा
यहां पर यहां पर रिस्पांस एक आया हुआ है
इस रिस्पांस में हम ट्राई आउट कर सकते खो
सकते कुछ अगर हमें मिलता है तो सो इट्स ल
इनक्रिप्टेड फॉर्म ऑफ थिंग्स सो एवरीथिंग
इ जस्ट इंक्रिप्टेड यर यहां पर आप देखेंगे
इंक्रिप्शन एंडर ये सारी चीज मिल रही है
तो
र फॉरवर्ड करते हैं फॉरवर्ड करते हैं
फॉरवर्ड करते हैं फॉरवर्ड करते करते हैं
कुछ खास हमें यहां पे देखने को मिल नहीं
रहा है सो वी आर नॉट फाइंडिंग समथिंग
इंटरेस्टिंग हियर एंड जस्ट इसके लिए हम
जैसे अ यहां पे लॉगिन है ऑलरेडी वीी आर
जस्ट ऑलरेडी लॉग इन हियर राइट तो हम दूसरे
इसके पेजेस को भी एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं
जैसे अभी भी हिस्ट हिस्ट्री पे चलेंगे हम
स्टडी हिस्ट्री पे चलेंगे तो हम बहुत सारी
चीजें यहां पे डिटेल्स यहां पे हमारे पास
आ रहे हैं राइट जिसन वेब टोकन हमारे पास
कुछ खास यहां आ नहीं र है एडमिन कंट्रोल
पैनल स्ट्रोल टोकन आया हुआ है यहां पे कुछ
इस तरीके का बट हमारे किसी काम का तो यह
नहीं लग रहा है इसको यूज करते
हैं इस पलट को देखते हैं इफ य कैन फाइंड
समथिंग नो नो नो नथिंग इज
देयर इसको कॉपी कर लेते हैं एक बार देखते
हैं व्हाट इज
दिस
ओके ओके सो देयर इज समथिंग देर इ समथिंग
बीसी ओ है यहां पे एंड सेशन जो है यहां पे
वो एक सेशन यहां पे आपको मिल रहा है टोकन
मिल रहा है यहां पे आप इस टोकन को भी
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं लाइक इफ देयर इज सम
काइंड ऑफ इनकोडिंग और समथिंग लाइक दैट एंड
इसको आप ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं देखने के
लिए फिलहाल के लिए हम इसको विजिट करते हैं
और भी चीजें यहां पे हैं बहुत सी चीजें जो
वी कैन विजिट आउट हम इंटरसेप्ट को फिलहाल
के लिए बंद कर देते हैं इंटरसेप्ट को यहां
पे हम ऑफ करते हैं एंड वी विल जस्ट विजिट
इट तो मैं यहां पे क्या कर देता हूं
मार्केटिंग टैम में चलता हूं यहां पे
एंड कैन सी दैट वी कैन डू समथिंग तो यहां
सेटिंग्स वगैरह प चलते
[संगीत]
हैं मार्केटिंग से बाहर आ जाते हैं माय
प्रोफाइल पर चलते
हैं हा प्रोफाइल इंफो प चलते हैं यहां पे
इफ यू कैन सी व्ट प्रोफाइल इंफो इज देयर
तो मिस्टर परफेक्ट प्रोफाइल इंफो है ईमेल
एड्रेस प चलते हैं कुछ इस तरीके का ईमेल
एड्रेस है यहां पे न्यू ईमेल एड्रेस अगर
आप चेंज करना चाहे तो यू कैन जस्ट चेंज इट
पासवर्ड प चलते हैं तो करंट पासवर्ड एंड
न्यू पासवर्ड चेंजिंग का भी यहां पे तो
दिस वन कैन बी चेक्ड आल्सो तो आप ईमेल
एड्रेस भी जो है उसको भी चेक कर सकते
हैंटी हिस्ट्री के लिए आप यहां से भी देख
सकते हैं कुछ हमें डिटेल्स कुछ हमें जस
टोकस मिलते हैं तो यहां पे कुछ मिला हमें
वन जेडल आ रहा है जेडब्ल्यू आ रहा है ठीक
है जेडब्ल्यू ई आ रहा है अगेन जे डब् यूजर
सेटिंग्स में जे डब् ई आ रहे जेडब्ल्यू टी
अगर हमें कुछ मिलता है तो इट्स ग्रेट तो
यहां पे जेडब्ल्यू टी ट्राई कीजिए फाइंड
करने का इंक्रिप्टेड आप फाइंड करेंगे तो
उसमें दिक्कत है फिर यहां पे एक जेडब्ल्यू
आया है कॉफिंग इंटरनल एपीआई बट इट्स नॉट
बट स्टिल हमारे काम का यह नहीं है जस ऑन
वेब टोकन बिकॉज जेडब्ल्यूएस तो है बट
अच्छा देख लेते हैं यहां पे इसका पेलोड का
कुछ है तो यहां पे पेलोड इफ वी कैन सी
पेलोड 256 यूज हो रही है जेडटी है राइट
क्लिक करके सेंड टू रिपीटर करते हैं एंड
देखते हैं इफ वी कैन गेट सम पेलोड्स
ओके सो हियर वी आर एंड हियर यर र यहां पर
हमें दिस वन सो जस्ट कॉपी दिस वन एंड
लेट्स सी इफ वी कैन गेट समथिंग हमें कुछ
मिला नहीं यहां पे बेस
64 नॉट नो इनकोडिंग यूआरएल एचटीएमएल
यूआरएल किसी से भी नहीं है ब यर इनकोडेड
नहीं है य पर इससे तो नहीं है बिल्कुल भी
नहीं है और यहां पर अगर हम टोकन सिग्नेचर
का देखें तो या र द सिग्नेचर
[संगीत]
एंड हेर थिंग सो यहां पर भी कुछ हमें खास
य देखने को तो मिला नहीं है य पर एक् टोकन
है य पर और कुछ नहीं है सो वीर नॉट गेटिंग
एनीथिंग सो लेट्स गो टू द प्रॉक्सी लेट्स
लेट्स
एक्सप्लोर सम मोर सेटिंग्स राइट तो यहां
पर हम पासवर्ड पर चलते हैं य पर पासवर्ड
में पासवर्ड करंट पासवर्ड वगर चेंज करने
की कोशिश करते हैं यहां पर जस्ट तो करंट
पासवर्ड में डालता
हूं क्या पासवर्ड
था तो हमने डाला यहां पर न्यू पासवर्ड
डालते हैं
एंड यहां
पर यहां पर डाला
मैंने न्यू पासवर्ड डाल दिया हमने अब यहां
पर हम चेंज करते हैं पासवर्ड को एंड देखते
हैं य प चेंज पासवर्ड यहां पर लॉगइन लॉग
आउट कर देते
हैं ठीक
है कोई बात नहीं हम लॉग आउट हो जाएंगे फिर
से लॉगइन कर सकते हैं तो यहां पर हम लॉग
आउट नहीं अभी ल लग आउट नहीं हुए अब य
देखते हैं कुछ हमें रिजल्ट मिले क्या
पासवर्ड चेंज हमने जब किया तो जेसन से
रिलेटेड कुछ मिला जेडब्ल्यू कुछ नहीं मिला
यहां पर एडमिन कंट्रोल स्टो टोकन यहां पे
ऑन इंक्रिप्टेड फॉर्म में वन जडब्ल्यू
यहां मिला है इंटरनल एपीआई वाली है ये तो
इट्स नॉट यूजफुल सेम टोकन इज देयर सो वी
आर नॉट फाइंडिंग एनी काइंड ऑफ टोकन यहां
पे कुछ एक्सपोज टोकन आपको यहां पे बेसिकली
मिल नहीं रहा है ठीक है तो अगर ऐसा
सिचुएशन है जब आपको कोई चीज लाइक कोई खास
टोकन आपको नहीं मिल पा रही है तो यू हैव
टू जस्ट मूव ऑन टू द डिफरेंट नेक्स्ट
थिंग्स लाइक दूसरी चीजों पे आपको स्टोर के
अलावा फिर दूसरी चीज एक्सप्लोर करनी
पड़ेगी एंड उस परे ट्राई आउट करना पड़ेगा
तो जैसे यहां पे एप्स है
यहां पे आप एटीटीपी हिस्ट्री को बस मॉनिटर
करते रहिएगा यहां पे आपको जब भी टोकेंस
मिल सकते हैं कहीं से भी जैसे मैं यहां पे
अब चलता हूं अकाउंट सेटिंग में यूजर्स पे
चलते हैं यहां पे यू कैन सी यर यूजर्स
यहां पे आपको दिख रहे हैं यहां पे क्रिएट
अ न्यू यूजर अकाउंट आप यहां से न्यू यूजर
अकाउंट भी क्रिएट कर सकते हैं यहां पे आप
जो भी यूजर रोल वगैरह है ये सब असाइन कर
सकते हैं राइट तो यहां पे ये इंटरेस्टिंग
हो सकता है कि यूजर रोल में आपको कुछ यहां
मिल जाए तो मैं यहां पे ईमेल आईडी डाल
देता हूं कोई सा भी ईमेल आईडी तो मैं यहां
पे यूज करता हूं टेंप में
टेंप मेल में यूज करूंगा एंड आई विल जस्ट
एंटर द यूजर आईडी
राइट अभी देखिए व विल यूज द यूजर आईडी यर
मम मेल को यूज कर लेते
हैं कॉपी यहां ईमेल आईडी डाला हमने एक्टिव
डाल दिया यहां पे अब यूजर का रोल देना है
तो सेल्स स्टाफ देना है सेल्स मैनेजर देना
है स्टोर एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर देना है तो कोई
सा भी आप दे सकते हैं मैं यहां पर क्या
करता हूं स्टोर सेल्स या स्टोर
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर सेल स्टाफ ही रखते हैं चलो
मैनेज ऑर्डर एडिट ऑर्डर ये सारा कुछ कर
सकता है ठीक है बाकी सारी चीजें सिस्टम
एडमिन परमिशन में मैनेज यूजर्स कर सकता है
ये स्टोर लेवल ए स्टोर लेवल यह सारी चीजें
हटा देते हैं बाकी कुछ नहीं करते यहां पे
हम सेव पे क्लिक कर देते हैं राइट सो इतना
हमने दिया अब हम इसको करते हैं हम यहां पे
स्ट हिस्ट्री देखते हैं इफ वी कैन गेट
समथिंग तो यहां पे आपको एक j अभी देखो जेड
ही मिला यहां पे परफेक्ट स्टोर पे जेडटी
हमें नहीं मिला यहां पे वन जडब्ल्यू मेल
बॉक्स मिला है बट दिस इ टेंप मेल का है यह
तो यह किसी काम का नहीं है हमारे यह टेंप
मेल वाली चीज है तो इफ य कैन गेट समथिंग
लाइक देखते हैं य पर क्या है यह टेमल
में सो अगर हम रेस्प को देखें यहां से
यहां अगर हम कॉपी करते इसको सो व्ट इ दिस
रिस्पांस दिस रिस्पांस
इज
ओके इसको रिस्पांस को हम यहां से लेके
ना यहां तक करें या यहां से थोड़ा आगे
बढ़ाते हैं राइट
सो यहां देखते हैं इफ वी कैन गेट समथिंग
क्या है यह
डॉट दिस माइट बी समथिंग इंटरेस्टिंग
डिकोडेड फ्रॉम यूआरएल कोडिंग डिकोडेड
फ्रॉम यूआरएल कोडिंग तो हमें यहां पे एक
ओके इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है ये दिस इज
इंटरेस्टिंग यहां पे आपको टोकन मिल रहा है
यह रिस्पांस में आपको टोकन मिल रहा है यह
टोकन मेल बॉक्स टेंप मेल का है यहां पे तो
अगर आप इस टोकन को एनालाइज करेंगे तो यहां
ये जेसन वेब टोकन है और इसके हम अगर पेलोड
पार्ट को देखें तो व्हाट इज देयर पेलोड
पार्ट में यहां पे यूयू आईडी मिल रही है
आपको मेल बॉक्स जो ईमेल आईडी है वो है एंड
आईटीए ये चीज ये ईमेल आईडी मिल रही है
आपको तो इट दिस कुड बी दिस कुड बी आल्सो
वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग किसी और डोमेन ये डोमेन
है ओजी हम उसपे अभी ट्राई आउट मार रहे हैं
जो भी जहां जसन मिल जाए भाई वहां ट्राई
आउट मार लो यहां पे यूयू आईडी करके यहां
पे मिल रही है तो इस रिस्पांस को हम
बेसिकली सेंड टू रिपीटर कर देते हैं
देखते हैं यहां
पर सेंड करते हैं रिस्पांस हमें मिलेगा
यहां पर यह रिस्पांस हमें मिल चुका है
टोकन हमें यहां पर मिल चुका है मेल बॉक्स
यहां पे इस मेल बॉक्स का यहां प कर कुछ और
रहे थे मिल कुछ और बेनी पोक करके कुछ आ
रहा है यहां पे
राइट दिस कैन बी एक्चुअली
इंटरेस्टिंग तो मैं यहां पर जसन वेब टोकन
प चलता हूं यहां पे अब यहां प एल्गोरिदम
ए5 6 यूज हो रही है जेडब्ल्यूडी यहां पे
यूज हो रहा है अब इस टोकन को हम बेसिकली
ना ब्रूट फोर्स करने की कोशिश कर सकते हैं
वी कैन ट्राई टू ब्रूट फोर्स दिस
पर्टिकुलर टोकन जो हमें यहां पे टोकन मिला
है ना इसको भी हम रूट फोर्स कर सकते हैं
जैसे कि मान लो मेरे पास यह टोकन है पूरा
का पूरा दिस होल टोकन इज देयर राइट यह
पूरा का पूरा टोकन हमने यहां से कॉपी कर
लिया और इसको हैकेट पे ले चलते
हैं एंड लेट्स ट्राई टू हैश कट इट तो हैश
कट करते हैं माइनस अटैक मोड जीरो रखते हैं
माइनस अ हैश मोड जो है वो 16500 का कर
देते हैं जो हमारा जेसन वेब टोकन के लिए
है यहां पे हम अपना टोकन डाल देते हैं जो
हमारा टोकन है एंड देन जो है हम इसमें जो
वड लिस्ट है हमारा वो वर्ड लिस्ट डाल देते
हैं तोय वड लिस्ट जो है आपका वो है होम के
अंदर डेनिक्स के अंदर वर्डलिस्ट के अंदर
एंड जेडटी वर्डलिस्ट तो इसम हम ट्राई आउट
कर सकते हैं इफ वी कैन एक्चुअली यहां पे
क्रैक तो यहां पे एग्जॉस्ट आ रहा है यहां
पे आई थिंक इट्स नॉट क्रैक्ड डिवा जनरेटर
देख लेते हैं यहां पे या इट्स नॉट क्रैक
राइट तो यह भैया कोई क्रैक नहीं कर पाए
यहां पे इट्स नॉट क्रैक यहां प क्या आ रहा
है यहां पे एस्टेड आ रहा है स्टेटस में
एस्टेड आ रहा है आपका तो बेसिकली जो है आप
इसमें लिस्ट आप इसमें अलग से एक ग्राफिक्स
यूज कर सकते हैं जैसे आप शड हान एच करेंगे
ना सकट हाइन एच करेंगे
तो हम यहां पर स्पेसिफिक डिवाइस यूज कर
सकते हैं डिवाइस टाइप में जीपीयू यूज कर
सकते हैं तो सेकंड नंबर जो है आपका वो
जीपीयू है तो हम डिवाइस जो है टाइप वह यूज
कर लेते हैं तो उसको ऊपर चल देते हैं यहां
पे सेकंड
नंबर यहां पर देखेंगे श अ एंड यहां पे
पनस यस
प्रन शश मोड्स तो हम यूज लेडी वी आर
डूइंग श टाइप हमने यहां पर कर लिया अटैक
मोड हमने यहां पर मेंशन कर दिया है आईन ए
के लिए यहां पर एंड जस्ट वी आर ंग टू गिव
द
रिस्टोर वगर यह सब कुछ है
नहीं इनकोडिंग यूजर नेम यह सब नहीं कर य
पे सी यूज नहीं करेंगे यहां पर ओपन सेल
डिवाइस के लिए फफडी यूज कर लेंगे हम यहां
पर तो डीटू यूज कर लेते हैं ठीक है ना सेम
कमांड देते हैं एंड नडी के बाद ू यूज कर
लेते हैं व विल जस्ट यूज द
टू तो यहां पे हमने ये चीज दे दिया ऑप्शंस
पहले यहां देते हैं तो ऑप्शंस में हम यहां
नडी 2 यूज कर लेते हैं जीपीयू का यूज करते
हैं देखते हैं इफ इट कैन एक्सेस एक्चुअली
सो हान डी एंड टू यूज कर लेते हैं लेट्स
सी इफ वी कैन सो कोई डिवाइस ही इसको नहीं
मिला है क्या बात है
यार ऐ लाइक ये परमिशन नहीं है फिर इसका
मतलब जीपीयू का तो चलिए वन सीपीयू यूज कर
लेते हैं बाय डिफॉल्ट वही होगा तो सीपीयू
तो इसको मिल ही जाएगा सो एग्जॉस्ट है यहां
पे
ओबवियसली उतना इसको मेमोरी ही एलोकेट नहीं
हो पा रहा है मेमोरी ही नहीं मिल पाती है
उसको उतनी तो जीपीयू के लिए उतना आपको
बेसिकली देना पड़ेगा यहां पे वी कैन जस्ट
गिव इट इट तो यहां पे हम एक काम कर लेते
हैं लेट्स ओपन
द एडिया कंट्रोल पैनल
प्रोग्राम सेटिंग्स पर चलते हैं य
पे
ओके ठीक है यहां पर हम डब्लू एसएल को ना
एक बार ट्राई करते हैं इफ वी कैन जस्ट गिव
इट ट्राई
इस
डब्लू नॉट दिस डब् एसल
डल चलिए यहां पर हम डब्ड ड्ड डब्लू डब्लू
डब्लू
एसएल यहां पर इसका लोकेशन देख लेते हैं
लोकेशन के अंदर चल लेते हैं ओके
सो
wsl2 एडिया का यहां पे इसको वोह दे देते
हैं ऑटो सेलेक्ट में एविया का वो दे देते
हैं डब्ल्यू एसएल को अप्लाई कर देते हैं
यहां पे
सो वी हैव अप्लाइड इट राइट नाउ सो वी
अप्लाइड इट राइट सो हमने य पर अप्लाई कर
दिया है ट्स ग्रेट ट्स
ग्रेट अब जो है यहां पर इसको क्लोज कर
देते हैं एंड जस्ट वी आर जस्ट क्लोजिंग
दिस
टर्मिनल हमने जीपीयू का वो दिया है अब आई
डोंट नो कि इट विल वर्क और नॉट
एटली स्टिल ल ट्राई राइट तो हम डल को
स्टार्ट कर लेते एक बार यहां पर एंड यहां
पर हम डेनिक्स में लॉगइन हो चुके हैं
राइट तो यहां पे कैट ईटीसी ओस रिलीज आप
देखेंगे तो यहां पे डॉकर आपका आ चुका है
लेस करते हैं यहां पे ओके सो दिस इज
इनसाइड द डब्ल्यू एएल तो अब हम यहां पे
बेसिकली क्या करेंगे लॉग इन करके एक बार
एक बार जस्ट वील जस्ट गिविंग इट ट्राई कि
अगर यह काम करता है नहीं करता है व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग सो यन 2ex ओपन कर लेते हैं यहां
पे दैट्ची
तो यहां पे हम कमांड डालते हैं यह वाली
कमांड है आपकी d2 करके हम देते हैं यहां
पे एंड इफ डिवाइस इज फाइंडिंग सो अभी भी
डिवाइस फाइंड नहीं कर रहा है कोई बात नहीं
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है यहां पे मैं d1 करके
एक बार ट्राई आउट कर लेता हूं इफ यू कैन
जस्ट क्रैक दिस पर्टिकुलर
टोकन सो d1 एंड लेट्स
सी अगेन सेम जॉस्ट ठीक है तो यहां पे हमें
कोई ये टोकन बेसिकली क्रैक नहीं कर रहा है
ये दिस नॉट इट्स नॉट क्रैकिंग फिलहाल के
लिए इस तरीके से तो हम क्रैक नहीं कर पा
रहे हैं बट यहां पे हमें जब टोकन मिल चुका
है यहां पे एक टोकन मिला है तो वी विल
ट्राई टू फाइंड आउट ऑल द थिंग्स तो हमें
यहां पे टोकन जब मिल रहा है तो हम इस टोकन
को यहां पे
जेडल जेडटी आओ पे चलेंगे आईओ या ओ दोनों
पे कर सकते हैं आप यहां पे तो यहां पे
मैंने इसको डाला एंड यहां पे आप देख सकते
हैं यहां पे एक यूआरएल मिल रही है पिक्सल
करके कुछ करके यहां पे जो मिल रही है ये
वो ईमेल आईडी मिल रही है इ कॉ कुछ करके
ऐसा मिल रहा है जेडटी यहां पर मिल रहा है
एंड यहां पर आपको यूयू आईडी मिल रही है सो
दिस यूयू आईडी कैन बी इंटरेस्टिंग थिंग
एंड यहां पे 2256 बिट सीक्रेट की आपसे
मांग रहा है कि अगर आपके पास सीक्रेट की
है तो अगर
आपने कर लिया है लाइक क्रैक वगैरह कर लिया
है या क्रैक हो पाया तो आप सीक्रेट की को
यहां पे डाल सकते हैं वी कैन जस्ट पुट इट
ऑन राइट
चलिए अब यहां पे आ जाते
हैं इफ न सी अगर हम यहां पे कोई चेंजेज
करते हैं तो हम यहां पे मिस कन्फेशन देख
सकते हैं किसी जह कोई मिस कन्फेशन है जैसे
कि मैं एल्गोरिदम को अगर मैं इस पर्टिकुलर
एल्गोरिदम को यहां पे हटा दूं लेट्स सपोज
वी आर जस्ट रिमूव मैं रिपीटर पे हूं यहां
पे ठीक है ना आईम रिट आई एम ऑन द रिपीटर
एंड इफ आई कैन जस्ट रिमूव दिस पर्टिकुलर
एल्गोरिदम एंड मैं कुछ कर पाऊ अगर में तो
वो हम ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं तो यहां पे
मैं एल्गोरिदम
[संगीत]
को यहां पे जसन एडिट पे आप आ चुके हैं एंड
रॉ प चलते हैं यहां पे एंड जस्ट कॉपी दिस
पर्टिकुलर
थिंग
पेलोड जस्ट कॉपिंग इट पेलोड यहां
पे राइट ट्स ग्रेट लेट्स कॉपी द सिग्नेचर
हियर अब यहां पे एक बार वेब टोकन पे चलके
एंड इफ यी कैन सी अ नो नो नो नो तो हमें
यहां पे तो कुछ यहां देखो अगर हम यहां पे
चेंज करते हैं मान लो किसी तरह का कोई
चेंजेज अगर हम करते हैं यहां पे तो वी हैव
टू स्टिल साइन द टोकन अगर आप साइन करेंगे
अगर अगर वो बेसिकली क्योंकि यहां पे अगर
आप साइन सही की से नहीं कर पाएंगे तो यू
विल नॉट गेट द डिजायर्ड रिजल्ट्स राइट तो
आपको फिर वो काम भी वैसे भी नहीं करेगा तो
हम जस्ट ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं ये देखने
का कि इफ इट इज वर्किंग काइंड ऑफ थिंग कि
हम इसमें कोई चेंजेज करके इसमें कोई वो
देख सकते हैं तो हम यहां पर आएंगे अगर
यहां पर इस पर्टिकुलर लोकेशन पर और अगर हम
यहां पर क्या करते हैं एल्गोरिदम को नन
करके एंड इ यू वांट टू मेक सम चेंजेज
समथिंग चेंस करना चाहते हैं कुछ ऐसा तो
एल्गोरिदम को मैं यहां पर अगर मान लो नन
कर दो ठीक
है कनॉट
पहले यहां पे एक बार चेंज करते हैं यहां
पे
लॉगइन यहां
पे ईमेल आईडी कोई एक चेंज करते हैं लेट्स
चेंज द ईमेल आईडी तो मैं ईमेल आईडी करता
हूं यहां पे हेलो @ h.com य मे आईडी डाला
हमने यू आईडी सेम यहां पे रहने देते हैं
यहां पे एल्गोरिदम यह सारी चीज सेम अब
यहां पे मैं यह जेडब्ल्यूडी टोकन बन गया
है इस टोकन को मैं यहां पे कॉपी कर लेता
हूं लेट्स सपोज आईम जस्ट कॉपिंग दिस टोकन
एंड अगर हम यहां पे इस टोकन को रिप्लेस
करते हैं लेट्स सपोज अगर आप इस टोकन को
पर्टिकुलर रिप्लेस करते हैं जो भी आपका
यहां पे टोकन है उसको अगर आप रिप्लेस करते
हैं एंड वहां पे रिप्लेस होके अगर ये ईमेल
आईडी चेंज हो जाती है पर्टिकुलर ईमेल आईडी
देन इट कैन बी अ वनबिल देन ये जो है आपका
वहां पे वनबिल आप कंसीडर इसको कर सकते हैं
फिलहाल के लिए हमारा जो ये टारगेट है ये
ऐसे हमें एक जेडब्ल्यूडी टोकन मिल चुका है
यहां पे अब यहां पे रिस्पांस में आप
बेसिकली चाहे तो चेंजेज जो करना है आप कर
सकते हैं लाइक व्हाट एवर यू कैन ट्राई आउट
एंड यू कैन जस्ट अ सी की अगर कुछ टोकन
मैनिपुलेट करके एंड उसका फिर हम आउटकम देख
पाए तो वो हम काम कर सकते हैं फिलहाल के
लिए इसके और जैसे कि अगर हम यहां पे वेब
इसका ही है सेम है यहां पे वेब टेंप मेल
का है यहां पे एंड यहां पे अगेन वेब टेंप
मेल है यहां पे हमारे काम का नहीं है
फिलहाल दिस इज टम मेल टम मेल टेंप मेल
टेंप मेल अगेन टेंप मेल ऑलवे ओनली टेम मेल
आपको मिल रहा है यहां पे मैक्सम टाइम ओके
ओके ओके ओके ओके ओके कुछ मिला यहां तो कुछ
नहीं है यहां जेडब्ल्यू जेडब्ल्यू आपको
इसमें तो पूरी ही मिल रही है जो भी चीजें
हैं अ वी कैन जस्ट ट्राई टू फाइंड आउट अब
जैसे यहां पे भी कोई है यहां पे कोई
पैरामीटर है तो आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे
फिलहाल के लिए जसन वेप टोकस यहां पे आपके
आ रहे हैं यहां पे h26 एंड यहां पे आ रहे
हैं तो इसमें मैसेजेस में आपके आ रहे हैं
तो यू कैन जस्ट ट्राई आउट टू चेक इफ जैसे
कि ये मिला तो मैं सेंड टू रिपीटर कर दूं
अगर इसको एंड यहां पे अगर सेंड करते हैं
यहां पे तो रिस्पांस में 200 ओके करके
यहां पे आ रहा है बेनी पोक करके ईमेल आईडी
आ रही है मैसेज इस तरीके से आ रहा है और
यह टोकन है आपका ऑथराइजेशन बरर यह रहा तो
अगर इस टोकन को आप यहां से स्कैन कर कॉपी
करते पलट को तो यह बेनी पकारा यू आईडी आ
रही है आईआईटी कुछ करके इस तरीके से आ रहा
है और यहां जब हम करेंगे हेडर को तो जेडटी
एचएस 256 आ रही है यहां पे ट्स ग्रेट एंड
यहां यह आपका जो
है टोकन आ रहा है जैसे वेब टोकन प आएंगे
तो तो जसन व टोकन पे आके आप यहां पे
चेंजेज कर सकते हैं एनी काइंड ऑफ चेंजेज
जो चाहते हैं आप करना तो बेसिकली अगर मैं
इस पर्टिकुलर ईमेल को चेंज करने की कोशिश
करूं इस पाथ को तो वो हम ट्राई आउट कर
सकते हैं वी कैन जस्ट गिव इट अ ट्राई तो
हम क्या करते हैं व्हाट व विल डू पहली बात
तो ये टोकन है आपके तो इस टोकन को भी आप
ब्रूट फोर्स करने की कोशिश कर सकते हैं जो
भी टोकन आपको मिल रही है आप ब्रूट फोर्स
करने के लिए पहले ट्राई कर लीजिए इफ इट
कैन ब्रूट फोर्स इट कैन बी ब्रूट फोर्स
ठीक है तो मैं यहां पे क्लियर कर देता हूं
एंड यहां पे मैं पेस्ट करता
हूं सॉरी मैं यहां पे सेम प्रीवियस कमांड
यहां लाता हूं एंड यहां पे मैं यह सेम
टोकन को जो है पेस्ट कर देता हूं ठीक है
यहां पे मैं
अ रिमूव कर देता हैं यहां टोकन पेस्ट किया
एंड एंटर करते हैं अगर कुछ कर पाता है यह
तो यहां पे फिलहाल के लिए कुछ खास है नहीं
यहां पे वर्क स्पे वर्कलोड एडजस्ट यहां पे
कुछ मिला नहीं यहां पे ट्स फाइन टोटली
फाइन यहां पे अब हम इसमें कुछ मिस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन ढूंढने की कोशिश करेंगे इफ
वी कैन फाइंड सम काइंड ऑफ़ मिस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन ठीक है किसी भी तरह का
मिसकॉन्फ़िगर्ड
मेल यूज करते हैं राइट तो हम यहां मेल कर
यूज जो करते हैं वो करते हैं हेलो @
h.com ठीक है ये मेल आईडी हमने कर दिया
मान लो अब ये मेल आईडी कर
दिया अब हम अगर सेंड पे क्लिक करते हैं तो
सेंड करने से पहले हमें क्या करना है हमें
यहां पे टोकन जो एल्गोरिदम है इसको नन कर
देते हैं फिलहाल के लिए नो एल्गोरिदम ऐसा
करके कर देते हैं देन यहां पे हम साइनिंग
ये जो की है की जो टोकन का की है उस की को
यहां पे हम रिमूव कर देंगे यह जो आपकी की
है लास्ट वाली इस की को आप रिमूव कर सकते
हैं बेसिकली रॉ पे चलेंगे यहां पे एंड वी
कैन जस्ट
सिंपली गेट इट रिमूव्ड
यहां से हम रिमूव कर देंगे जन वेब टोकन पे
चलेंगे सिग्नेचर हट चुकी है यहां पे यहां
नन कर दिया आपने और यहां ईमेल आईडी जो है
आपने लो @ hello.com किया और सेंड करेंगे
सेंड करेंगे तो यहां पे अब जैसे ही सेंड
करेंगे यहां पे आ रहा है अन ऑथराइज टू
एक्सेस दिस रिसोर्स यहां पे पे एरर नेम नथ
अन ऑथराइज एक्सेप्शन मतलब यहां पे
रिजल्ट्स में आपके दिक्कत आ रही है दिक्कत
आ रही है मतलब सिग्नेचर हमने यहां पे कुछ
छेड़छाड़ करी है तो यहां पे ये काम नहीं
कर रहा है इट्स नॉट एक्चुअली वर्किंग एंड
हमने ब्रूट फोर्स किया हमने ब्रूट फोर्स
अगर कर पाते हैं य कुछ रिजल्ट्स हमें आ
पाते हैं तो हम ब्रूट फोर्स करके भी ट्राई
आउट कर सकते थे राइट तो यहां पे हमने जब
छेड़छाड़ किया तो यहां पे नन करने पे यहां
पे कुछ भी नहीं आ रहा है अब यहां पे आप
सिंपली ऐसे भी कर सकते हैं कि आपका
एल्गोरिदम सेम रख सकते हैं एंड बिना किसी
पर्टिकुलर किसी भी तरह के सिग्नेचर से वो
करके जैसे मैं य बैक करता हूं यहां पर अब
य एरिम वही रखते हैं सिग्नेचर यहां पर सेम
सिग्नेचर यहां पर रखते हैं एंड अब हम क्या
करते
हैं यहां पर हमारा सिग्नेचर भी आ चुका है
सब कुछ आ चुका है हम यहां पर इसको रिमूव
करते
हैं य चेक करते हैं
हेलो हेलोड कॉ एंड यहां पर
अब सि
कोई भी रैंडम सिग्नेचर से साइन करके हम
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं लाइक व्हाट एवर
रैंडम सिग्नेचर इज देयर वी कैन जस्ट ट्राई
आउट तो हम जेडटी एडिटर प चलते हैं यहां पे
इसको हम डिलीट कर देते हैं जो हमने पहले
सिग्नेचर बनाया था जस्ट डिलीट इट यहां
न्यू सिमेट्री की करते हैं यहां पे एक
सिग्नेचर को जनरेट कर लेते हैं यहां पे
यहां पे सिग्नेचर आ चुकी है यहां पे अब हम
इस इसी पर्टिकुलर सिग्नेचर से इसको साइन
करने की कोशिश करेंगे यहां पे ओके कर देते
हैं रिपीटर पे चलते हैं यहां पे एंड यहां
पे अब साइन पे क्लिक करेंगे ये सिग्नेचर
जो जनरेट किया था वो सिग्नेचर आ गया hs256
करके हम ओके करते हैं यहां पे सिग्नेचर
चेंज हो चुका है एंड यहां पे अब ये चीज आ
चुकी है अब हम इसको करके देखते हैं इफ वी
कैन लिटरली कुछ कर सकते हैं क्या 401 अगेन
ये 401 आ गया एंड यहां पे आ रहा है अन
ऑथराइज टू एक्सेस दिस रिसोर्स तो यहां पे
ये काम नहीं कर रहा है इसी तरीके से आपको
अलग-अलग अप्रोचेबल फोर्स करना है अ
सिग्नेचर अ मिसकंफीग्रेशन देखनी है कोई
मिसकंफीग्रेशन है वो देखनी है तो फिलहाल
के लिए तो हमारे पास इस पर्टिकुलर चीज में
कुछ हमें यहां पे डिफाइन करके यहां पे इस
पर्टिकुलर टारगेट के लिए नहीं मिला है
लेकिन आप जो भी टारगेट को एक्सप्लोर करना
चाहे आप बस एक्सप्लोर कीजिए एक्सप्लोर
करते रहिए करते रहिए करते रहिए एंड आपको
कुछ अगर टोकेंस यहां पे कुछ भी यहां पे
मिल जाता है कोई भी जेसन टोकन मिलता है
किसी भी यूआरएल का आपको जेसन टोकन मिल
जाता है जेडटी स्पेशली मिल जाता है एंड
उसको आप ब्रूट फोर्स या कुछ कर पा रहे हैं
या समथिंग काइंड ऑफ तो दैट विल बी मच अ
योर अ लाइक मेन ट्रिगर थिंग एंड वहां पे
फिर आप उसको कर सकते हैं तो बेसिकली क्या
कर सकते हैं आप ये देख सकते हैं कि जो
आपका टोकन है वो टोकन में कोई मिस कन्फेशन
जैसे कि टोकन डिलीट जो सिग्नेचर है उसको
डिलीट कर दे रहे हैं एंड सिग्नेचर का
एल्गोरिदम नन करके उसको हम पास कर रहे हैं
तो क्या वो एक्सेप्ट हो रहा है दूसरा क्या
किसी भी रैंडम सिग्नेचर से हम उसको साइन
कर रहे हैं फिर हम डाटा चेंज कर रहे हैं
फिर हम अप्लाई कर रहे हैं सेंड कर रहे हैं
वो एक्सेप्ट हो रहा है क्या तीसरा क्या
ब्रूट फोर्स कर रहे हैं ब्रूट फोर्स अगर
कर पा रहे हैं किसी टोकन को ब्रूट फोर्स
करके अगर हमारे पास रिजल्ट्स आ जा रहे हैं
तो क्या ब्रूट फोर्स करने के बाद हमें
ब्रूट फोर्स करके अगर हम की से साइन करते
अगर हमारे पास ब्रूट फोर्स करके वो
सीक्रेट की ही आ गई फिर तो हम कुछ भी कर
सकते हैं वो हम कर पा रहे हैं क्या तो वो
सारा अटेंप्ट सारा जो अप्रोच है आपको यूज
करना है तो आपको सिंपली ब्राउज करना है जो
भी आपका पर्टिकुलर चीज अलग-अलग
फंक्शनैलिटीज है उसको ट्राई आउट करना है
उसको आपको ऐड और ये सब सारी चीजें करनी है
पेमेंट मेथड्स है यहां पे ईमेल है जैसे आप
ईमेल पे जाते हैं मैनेज ईमेल खुल गया
अपग्रेड स्टोर उसपे चले पेमेंट मेथड उसपे
चले जाते हैं स्टोर डिटेल्स उस चले जाते
हैं इनवॉइस एंड बिलिंग सारी यहां पे आ रही
है राइट अब यहां पे जब हम आ रहे हैं तो
यहां पे फिर से ये लॉगिन करने का ऑप्शन
आपको दिया जा रहा है क्योंकि हमने पासवर्ड
चेंज किया था राइट तो हम यहां पर लॉग इन
कर सकते हैं जो हमने लॉग इन किया
था तो यहां पर हम लॉगइन कर देते एक बार
अगेन इट विल बी लगड
इन आते तो यहां प देख सकते हैं कि ये
इनवॉइस आपका हो गया पेमेंट मेथड स्टोर
ईमेल ये सारी चीजें तो आप देख सकते हैं
यहां पे कि यहां पे सारी डिटेल्स आ रही है
यहां पे स्टोर अपग्रेड का आ रहा है यहां
पे आपका ये मैनेज बिलिंग मैनेज की आ रही
है इनवॉइस का आ रहा है सब कुछ आ रहा है अब
इसको भी देखो आप अब यहां भी देखो कि यहां
कोई जेडब्ल्यू t आपके सामने निकल के आ रही
है कि अभी जो आपने एक्सेस किया सो सम
जेडब्ल्यू t यू आर गेटिंग अब यहां देखो
यहां पे वन जडब्ल्यू ये टेंप मेल का आ रहा
है अब मैं यहां पे क्या कर सकता हूं व्हाट
आई कैन डू कि मैं यहां पे सेट कर सकता हूं
कि मुझे सिर्फ और सिर्फ कोई स्कोप आइटम्स
वाली जो दिखाई है वही दिखाइए जैसे मेरे को
चाहिए ओनली किससे बिक कॉमर्स से ठीक है
मैं यहां पे क्या कर देता
हूं मेरे को जो डिटेल्स चाहिए मैं चाहता
हूं कि सिर्फ बिक कॉमर्स से दिखे बाकी कोई
ना दिखे तो मैं इसको स्कोप में डाल
दूंगा यहां पे आ गए स्टोर वाली यह यूआरएल
है आपकी ठीक है तो ये स्टोर स्टोर करके आ
रहा है तो इसको करके ऐड टू स्कोप कर देंगे
यहां पे और यहां पे अब जाएंगे तो आप शो
ओनली इन स्कोप आइटम्स करेंगे तो आपको
सिर्फ इसके स्टोर वाले जो है वो आपको यहां
पर देखने को मिलेंगे राइट तो यह भी आप इस
तरह से करके आप हटा सकते हैं इसको वो कर
सकते हैं ठीक है या सिर्फ बिग कॉमर्स से
आपको चाहिए तो आप सिर्फ बिग कॉमर्स का जो
है वह भी आप कर सकते हैं ओनली बिग
कॉमर्स से आएगा
तो या लॉगइन ड बिक कमर्स आप चाहते हैं तो
यह भी आप कर सकते हैं इफ वी कैन यू कैन
सेट द जो यूआरएल हैका लॉगइन ब कमर्स है वो
कर सकते हैं तो फिलहाल के लिए हमें यहां
पर रिजल्ट्स में देखने को कुछ खास बिक
कॉमर्स
से जेडब्ल्यू तो नहीं मिला है हमें वी आर
नॉट फाइंडिंग एनी जेडब्ल्यू
राइट नो नो नो नो नो यह एक मिला है हमें
जीरो ये एक मिला है एडमिन रिमो पीए हाब
जेडल यहां पे हमें एक फाइ हुआ है
जेडब्ल्यू अगेन वी कैन सी इट्स
एनक्रिप्टेड जेडब्ल्यू जो कि हमें यहां
पे देखने को
मिलेगा रिस्पांस में यहां पे आपको यह चीज
मिल रही है जस्ट ट्राई इफ वी कैन सी तो
ऐसे आपको एक्सप्लोर करना है लाइक फ्लिपक
में भी आप जाइए
ठीक है अब जैसे मैं फप का ओपन कर लेता
हूं स ओपन द फप
राट मैं लॉग इन करता हूं एक बार
इसका सेइंग माय साइन अप एंड ल य लॉगइन कर
लेते हैं डायरेक्टली लॉगइन हो जा जल्दी हो
जा भाई यहां पर ईमेल और मोबाइल नंबर आपसे
पूछ रहा है तो मैं य पर मान
लो मोबाइल नंबर डाला मैंने ओटीपी
रिक्वेस्ट किया एंड सी लेटस इ देर ओटीपी
कमिंग ऑन द नंबर तो मैं य ओटीपी डाल देता
हूं अगर ओटीपी आता है तो यस ओटीपी आ चुका
है हमारे पास दिस ओटीपी इज
अ व्हाट द ओटीपी इज अरे भैया आज जा
भाई 9171 ठीक है किया हमने हम यहां पे लॉग
इन हो चुके हैं तो हम
इसको हम क्लोज ही कर देते हैं क्योंकि यह
बहुत ज्यादा दिक्कत दे रहा है इसको भी हम
क्लोज कर देते हैं एंड सी इफ वी कैन फाइंड
समथिंग राइट तो हम यहां पर कुछ अगर मिल
जाता है यहां पे तो इसको हम देख सकते हैं
कि इफ वी आर गेटिंग सम काइंड ऑफ
को यूज करता ही हो ऐसा जरूरी नहीं है राइट
तो आप देख सकते हैं सारी ओपन कीजिए एंड
यहां प देखते रहिए तो यहां
प या सो वी फाउंड सम जसन वेब टोकन ऑन
[संगीत]
तो यहां टोकन मिले
हमें सो एक्ली वी गट यर टोकन कांटेक्ट के
ऊपर में वॉलेट बैलेंस जो है यह वॉलेट
बैलेंस अच्छी चीज
है वॉलेट बैलेंस कहां पर है
भाई गिफ्ट कार्ड ओपन किया क्या हमने कुछ
यहां पर कोई एड्रेस नहीं है यहां पर कुछ
नहीं है
गिफ्ट कार्ड्स पर चलते
हैं ऐड गिफ्ट कार्ड प चलते हैं गिफ्ट
कार्ड नंबर यहां पे कुछ भी डाल दीजिए आप
पिन डाल दीजिए कुछ भी ऐड टू गिफ्ट कार्ड
टू अकाउंट कर दीजिए तो इनवैलिड कार्ड नंबर
आ रहा है ठीक है अच्छी बात है तो यहां पे
हम चेक कर सकते हैं अब यहां पे गिफ्ट
कार्ड में भी देखो यहां पे यहां पे गिफ्ट
कार्ड का लिंक आया इसमें 500 ये 500
स्टेटस कोड है तो हमारे काम का नहीं है
यहां पे हमें मिला है एक गिफ्ट का लोकेशन
यहां पे एक्टिव ग गिफ्ट कार्ड यहां पे
वॉलेट एक्टिव
इजी भी आ रहा है यहां पर ट्स ग्रेट थिंग
तो यहां पर एक आ रही है स्टेटस को 200 के
साथ दो जे डब्ल्यूटीए रहे हैं ऑर्डर आ रहा
है प्रीऑर्डर यूनिट्स आ रही है चलिए अच्छी
बात है प्रोडक्ट समरी आ रहा है ठीक है
एंड यह अच्छी चीज है चलो यह वाला हम देख
लेते हैं एक बार ईजीवी एक्टिव ईजीवी गिफ्ट
कार्ड वाला देख लेते हैं यहां पर
[संगीत]
ये तो राइट क्लिक करते हैं इसको एंड सेंड
टू रिपीटर पे क्लिक कर देते हैं रिपीटर प
चलते हैं यहां पे एंड रिपीटर प आप चलेंगे
तो इसको आप जब सेंड करेंगे तो यू विल गेट
द रिस्पांस ऑफ 200 ओके राइट तो यहां पे
आपको यह रिस्पांस मिल रहा है रिस्पांस में
क्या मिल रहा है देख लेते
हैं नो ई गिफ्ट कार्ड फाउंड यहां नल नल एस
एंड
नल ये चीजें आ रही है स्टेटस को 200 ठीक
है अब यहां पे जब आप आएंगे तो यहां पे
आपको ना
मिलेगा रॉ में जेसन वेब टोकन ठीक है तो हम
देख लेते हैं कहां पर है यह रहा हमारा एक
जेसन वेब टोकन यह रहा तो इसके हम पेलोड को
देखते हैं पेलोड के अंदर क्या इंफॉर्मेशन
है
भाई इ द पेलोड
यार फर्स्ट हेडर इज
दिस सो हेड इंफॉर्मेशन में यहां पे एचएस
256 जड है यहां पे के आईडी आपको मेंशन है
यहां पे के आईडी यहां पर दी गई है कुछ इस
तरीके से एंड इट्स इंटरेस्टिंग पेलोड आपका
यह है तो पेलोड की डॉट को हम ढूंढ रहे हैं
वेयर इ द पलट डॉट एंडिंग लॉन्ग पलट यह पलट
है क्या यार इसका पलट का डॉट पहले एंड हो
जाना चाहिए था
राइट आई थिंक आई एम मिसिंग द
डॉट ब दूसरा डॉट तो हमारा यही है न नॉट
फाइंड एनी काइंड ऑफ पेलोड इंफॉर्मेशन
हियर या एंड व्हाट अबाउट दिस वन दिस वन इज
नथिंग चलिए एक और यहां पर मिला हमें तो
यहां पे हमारा पेलोड कहां है दिस शुड बी द
पेलोड यह रहा पेलोड यवाई से लेके एंड यहां
से लेके यहां तक का पेलोड है आपका सो इट्स
नॉट गेटिंग द या यह रहा बेस 64 ये आपका
पेलोड आपको मिल चुका है यहां पे दिस पेलोड
वी गॉट इट हियर यू इन कोडिंग ऊपर में भी
फिर आपको पेलोड मिलेगा ही मिलेगा यहां पर
आप जाएंगे एंड वी कैन सी द पेलोड यर सो
बीस 64 यह पेलोड आपको दिख रहा है यहां पे
सो वी आर फाइंडिंग द पेलोड हियर एटली वी
आर फाइंडिंग द पेलोड हियर अब देखो पेलोड
में क्या क्या है यहां पे इ यल सी
एक्सपायरी
आईटी जेटी आई कुछ यहां पर टाइप ए है
डीआईडी यहां पर आपको कर र य के यहां प मैप
इ यू कैन सी एनीथिंग
इंटरेस्टिंग एम
एपीआई यहां पर बेस 64 इनकोडिंग यहां पर
पड़ी है यहां पर एक एंड ई आईडी अगर आप बेस
64 इनकोडिंग है यहां पर इस तरीके से इसको
हम कॉपी कर ले और इसको हम डिकोड करने की
कोशिश करें एम ट्रू है यहां पर सीएस एल आई
है तो हम यहां पर डिकोडर पर चल सकते हैं
एंड डिकोडर पर हम इसको रिमूव करके यहां
डिकोडर यहां यह डाल के एंड डिकोड एस बेस
64 तो कुछ इस तरीके से हमें डिकोड वैल्यू
मिली है बेस 64
का ब 64 में कुछ यह डिटेल्स हमें मिले हैं
नॉट गेटिंग सम काइंड ऑफ रिजल्ट्स यर चलो
स्मार्ट डिकोड करते
हैं नहीं आ रहा कुछ भी डिकोड
एस कुछ खास हमें नहीं मिला है यहां पर बट
या वी आर फाइंडिंग द डिटेल्स यर वी आर
फाइंडिंग द डिटेल्स र जसन यहां पर चलेंगे
अब जेसन वेब टोकन प चलते हैं य प देखते य
के आईडी तो मिली य प एल्गोरिदम ए 256 य पर
अच्छी बात है पेलोड में देखो जन फ ट्रू
फील्स है एस एच आईडी एल आई ट्रू बस यह
पेलो है य प य के आईडी मैप एपीआई बी आईडी
टाइप ड के समथिंग अगर कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग हो
तो मजा आ जाए कुछ चेंज कर केवलार ये इ जो
है एक केवलार करके है यहां पर डों नोस
आपको देखना पड़ेगा कि यह क्या है केवलार
ये आपको पता करना पड़ेगा देन आप चेंजेज
वगैरह कर सकते हैं य पे कुछ खास यहां पर
हमें डिटेल नहीं एम ट्रू है यहां
पे एच वाईज जन फो है यहां पे कुछ इस तरीके
से हमें मिली है मतलब कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग
हमें कुछ तो यहां पर मिला है जसन वेब टोकन
में उसी तरीके से यहां आप अकाउंट के लिए
भी जा सकते हैं लाइक इफ वी कैन सी
रिवार्ड्स यहां पे अफॉर्डेबिलिटी बीएनपी
अकाउंट यहां पे कुछ मिला है नथिंग एल्स
तो यहां पर आपको बाय या गिफ्ट कार्ड चेक
गिफ्ट कार्ड बैलेंस यह सब भी चेक आउट कर
सकते हैं बाय या गिफ्ट कार्ड पर आप आएंगे
तो यहां पर गिफ्ट कार्ड बाय करने का ऑप्शन
आएगा तो यहां प आपको कुछ मिल सकता है
गिफ्ट कार्ड लिंक यहां प 500 है यहां पे
लोकेश यहां प आ रही है डोमिनेशन आ रही है
यहां पे अलग-अलग डोमिनेशन आ रहे हैं सो
इंटरेस्टिंग इंटरेस्टिंग मैं बोलूंगा इसको
अ य एक बार
देखेंगे सी समथिंग इंटरेस्टिंग कुछ और
मिलता है तो यह क्या है जे डब् तो नहीं है
हमारे पास यहां प
इसमें
या जस्ट गिव इट ट्राई अब मैं यहां प ये तो
फप का प मैं कर रहा हूं यहां प मान लो
लेट्स सपोज सम अदर डोमेन आल्सो कोई और
डोमेन है हम उस पर भी ट्राई आउट कर सकते
हैं वी कैन जस्ट गिव इट ट्राई हमें कोई सा
भी डोमेन हो हम उस पर ट्राई हमें बस
एक्सप्लोर करना है वी हैव टू जस्ट
एक्सप्लोर इट राइट
बहुत अच्छी बात है बहुत अच्छी बात है न्यू
स्टूडेंट
ओके ओके चलिए अब यहां
पे हेलो सर आई गट योर चैनल वन मंथ अगो एंड
आई एम वाचिंग योर बग बाउटी सीरीज एंड नाउ
आई एम एट 43 लेक्चर एंड एवरी वीडियो इज
अमेजिंग थैंक यू ग्रेट ग्रेट बाउट द डीसी
जसपी बहुत अच्छी बात है बहुत अच्छी बात है
चलिए अब यहां पे हम अभी तो अभी अभी तो हम
अभी अभी तो हम देखेंगे भाई
कोई बताइए कोई लॉगिन फंक्शनैलिटी वाली
वेबसाइट हो जहां पे हम लॉगिन करें एंड
वहां पे हम ट्राई आउट मारे जो थोड़ी
पॉपुलर भी हो वो बताइएगा क्योंकि उसी पे
फिर हमें जेडब्ल्यूडी जो है टोकन वो
मिलेगी ठीक है तो एक बार बता दीजिए जल्दी
से फटाफट इफ वी कैन टेल प्लीज बताइए जल्दी
से अगर कोई है आपके उसमें कोई भी
पर्टिकुलर
वेबसाइट है तो आप बता सकते हैं जिस पर कि
हम जा सकते हैं एज टारगेट हम उसको यूज कर
सकते हैं इसी पर्टिकुलर चीज के लिए जहां
पर हम लॉग इन करें एंड चलिए हम मेक माय
ट्रिप वगैरह इन सब प भी जा सकते हैं वी
कैन जस्ट ट्राई आउट मेक माय ट्रिप
बॉब प्रॉक्सी इनेबल कर देते हैं एंड देन
हम लॉगइन कर लेते हैं गल से
राइट नितेश सिंह हैकर इसी से कर लेते हैं
अगर अकाउंट नहीं बना है तो कोई बात नहीं
बन
जाएगा यहां डाल कर दिया
हमने ओटीपी मंगा लेते हैं
फटाफट ओटीपी डाल देते हैं
ठीक है वेरीफाई कर लेते
हैं सो वी आर इनसाइड द मैमा टप अकाउंट आ
ओन अकाउंट हाई ट्रेवलर माय प्रोफाइल चलते
हैं माय प्रोफाइल पे यहां प अलग-अलग
प्रोफाइल्स है यहां पे ट्स ग्रेट एंड नाउ
वी कैन सी द बॉब सूट राइट या तो हमें देख
सकते हैं यहां पे ग का जेडब्ल्यू यहां पे
एक साइन ऑन है कोई बात नहीं यह एपीआई मिला
है
एड मैप एम एपीआई जो मिला है वो मिला है
हमें 200 ट्स ग्रेट यह एक अच्छी चीज है
पैरामीटर के साथ मिला है यह अच्छी चीज है
हमें जो एक मिली है यहां पे इस पर चलते
हैं ये क्या है ये मैप
एपीआई एक और मिला था हमें शायद कौन सी
मिली है
एंड रिक्वेस्ट पे हमें रिस्पांस मिला है
सक्सेस लॉगइन ऑथ टोकन यहां मिली है पर्सनल
इंफॉर्मेशन वगैरह तो यहां प कुछ
इंफॉर्मेशन अपडेट कर सकते हैं हम यहां पे
कुछ वेबसाइट जैसे नेम डालना है तो मैं
यहां पे नाम डाल देता हूं
नितेश यहां
पे बर्थडे बर्थडे डाल देता हूं यहां पे
अ बर्थडे डाल दिया यहां पे
अक्टूबर 22 22 अक्टूबर डाल दिया हमने यहां
पे उसके बाद एड्रेस डाल देते हैं अ न्यू
दिल्ली नहीं न्यू दिल्ली तो क्यों डालेंगे
यार एड्रेस में हां डाल दो न्यू
दिल्ली पिन को डाल
दिया यहां पे स्टेट डाल दिया डेल्ली ठीक
है एंड यहां पे सेव कर देते हैं सो वी गॉट
सम काइंड ऑफ डिटेल्स हियर सो हमें कुछ
डिटेल्स यहां पे आ चुके हैं पॉपलेट हो
चुके हैं यहां पे अब हम अगेन प्रॉक्सी पे
चलते हैं यहां पे एंड अगेन वी विल सी सम
काइंड ऑफ
टोकन ट सम का ऑ टोक
राइट सें टू
रिपीटर रिक्वेस्ट को सेंड करते
हैं सो य आ चुका है हमारा ईमेल आईडी आ
चुका है नितेश सिंह हैकर करके यहां पर एंड
यूयू आईडी करके आई है यहां पर ट्स
ग्रेट तो हम जेड टोकन य मिला है तो हम
इसका यूज करके देखेंगे एक बार व्ट काइंड
ऑफ टोकन एंड व्हाट काइंड ऑफ इंटरेस्टिंग
थिंग वी हैव गॉट जसन वेब टोकन पे चलते हैं
यहां
पे देखेंगे एल्गोरिदम आरस यहां पे केआ
आईडी जेडटी आ रही है अच्छी बात है पेलोड
में जब आप आएंगे तो पेलोड में आपको यहां
पे कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग फैक्टर्स दिखेंगे
जिसमें कि इज अ अकाउट google.com एप ठीक
है ये आली नितेश सिं हैकर @ gmail.com ये
ईमेल आईडी आपको मिल रहा है राइट सो दिस
ईमेल आईडी इज गेटिंग ईमेल वेरीफाइड ट्रू
है यहां पे ईमेल वेरीफाइड ट्रू आ रहा है
राइट तो ठीक है ये ट्रू आ रहा है ट्स
परफेक्टली फाइन एंड मिस्टर
परफेक्ट यहां मिस्टर परफेक्ट आ रहा है
जेटी एक्स यहां पर आ रहा है टीआई ट्स
ग्रेट यहां पर हम कुछ डिफरेंस ला सकते हैं
पिक्चर है यहां
पे ट्स ग्रेट यहां कुछ हम डिफरेंस ला सकते
हैं और हमारे पास यह टोकन है राइट जो यहां
पर हमें टोकन मिली है
सो वी हैव गट दिस पर्टिकुलर टोकन जहां पर
हमारा हेडर वैल्यू कुछ इस तरीके से
होगा यहां तक आपकी हेडर है यह आपका पार्ट
जो है वह पेलोड का है जहां पर दूसरा डॉट
ढूंढेंगे य कैन फाइंड द डॉट यह पेलोड है
आपका एंड यहां पर यह आपकी सिग्नेचर जो है
व आपकी सिग्नेचर हो गई राइट तो इस
को हम करके ट्राई करेंगे यहां
पर जस्ट गिव इट
ट्राई तो हम यहां पर अपना टोकन जो है वह
चेंज कर देते
हैं ए हम ट्राई करते हैं ी कैन जस्ट गेट
समथिंग आप यय ब्रूट फोर्स वाला चीज जरूर
करके देखिएगा अगर आपको कुछ मिल जाता है तो
इट कैन
बी नो हैश इ लोडेड ऐसा कैसे हो सकता है शश
लोड तो कर दिया
हमने चलो एक काम करते हैं यहां
पर कोई भी एक टोकन यहां से उठा लेते हैं
जो टोकन जिसकी वैल्यू हमें वहां पर मिल
रही थी तो वी आर गेटिंग द टोकन यर कहां
गया टोकन
भैया यह रहा टोकन तो यह टोकन एंड का पेलोड
पेलोड इसका पहले देख लेते हैं इस पेलोड
में हमें क्या डिटेल्स मिल जाते हैं पहले
ये देख लेते हैं सो हेयर इज द पेलोड
पार्ट यह रहा यह पलट पार्ट आ गया तो यहां
पर आपको सारी डिटेल्स आ रही है ठीक है तो
यह टोकन जो है उठा लेते हैं यहां से यहां
से लेके यहां तक हमने इस टोकन
को उठा लिया है अब इस टोकन को हम यहां पर
डिफाइन कर देते हैं
चलो एक बार फिर से वो कर देते हैं इतना
टाइम क्यों लगाना है कट हान ए टक मोड जीरो
रख देते हैं हान m 16500 कर देते हैं यहां
पे हम टोकन डिफाइन कर देते हैं एंड यहां
पे हम वड लिस्ट को डिफाइन कर देते हैं जो
हमारा वड लिस्ट है तो हमारा वड लिस्ट है
स्ल होम के अंदर स्ल
लोकल होम के
अंदर डेनिक्स के अंदर वर्डलिस्ट के अंदर
एंड जे डटी लिस्ट तो न टोकन एक् यहां पर
कुछ कुछ तो गड़बड़ हो रही है टोकन को
लेके र एंटरिंग सम रंग
थिंग्स ट यहां पर दिक्कत क्या रही है यहां
पर जेसन वेब टोकन पर चलते हैं य
पर बेसिकली जेडब्ल्यू यहां पर आपको आ रही
है मिल रही है ट्स ग्रेट
आ रहा
है यहां पर टोकन तो हमने बिल्कुल सही डाला
है यहां पर हम यहां से भी कॉपी करके अगर
डालते हैं
सो श कट हान ए अटैक मोड जीरो करते हैं एंड
हान ए से यहां पर हम डाल देते हैं
16500 देन
हाइन यहां पर हम
टोकन मेंशन कर देते हैं बिल्कुल सही है
टोकन हम बिल्कुल सही डाल रहे हैं अगर कुछ
इशू आ रहा है तो दैट इज सम इश्यूज देयर
तभी यह दिक्कत आ रही है तो अब यहां पे हम
कर देते हैं वड लिस्ट के अंदर में एंड
जेडब्ल्यू टी सीक्रेट्स यहां पे तो कोई
हैश यहां पे ये इसको कंसीडर नहीं कर रहा
फिलहाल के लिए ठीक है कोई कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है हम यहां पे हम यहां पे कुछ मिस कन्फेशन
देख लेते हैं इफ वी कैन डू समथिंग सम
काइंड ऑफ थिंग्स मिस कॉन्फिन अगर हम कुछ
देख पाए वहां से हम कुछ कर पाए तो वो हम
देख लेते हैं तो यहां पे हम एल्गोरिदम
rs256 जो है इसको फिलहाल के लिए हम नन कर
देते हैं अगर नन करके हम एक बार ट्राई आउट
मार लेते हैं क्या जाता है हमारा नन कर
लेते हैं यहां पे एंड देन वी विल जस्ट
ट्राई टू चेंज समथिंग तो
[संगीत]
उ ईमेल आईडी जो है ईमेल आईडी को हम चेंज
कर लेते हैं ईमेल आईडी इसके जगह पे हम
यहां पे लो @ अटकर कॉ डाल देते हैं ठीक है
एवरीथिंग इज़ फाइन ईमेल वेरीफाई ट्रू ही
रहने देते हैं ठीक है एंड यहां से हम
सिग्नेचर जो है हमारा इसमें से सिग्नेचर
इसको हम हटा देते हैं यहां पे डिलीट मार
देते हैं एंड यहां जो हमने सिग्नेचर डाला
है इस साइन को रिमूव कर देते हैं इस
सिग्नेचर को यहां से रिमूव कर देते हैं सो
रॉ पे चलते हैं यहां पे एंड वी जस्ट रिमूव
द सिग्नेचर सिग्नेचर पार्ट को जस्ट रिमूव
करना है तो आप यहां से भी कर सकते हैं जसन
वेप टोकन से है यहां पे सिग्नेचर है आप
इसको डिलीट मार दीजिए सिग्नेचर पार्ट यहां
से रिमूव हो जाएगा दैट्ची
दैट इनवैलिड टोकन अब यहां पे आप देख सकते
हैं यहां पे कि ये टोकन जो आ रहा है कि ये
इनवैलिड टोकन है मतलब टोकन इज नॉट वैलिड
क्योंकि हमने यहां पे बेसिकली टोकन ही
डिलीट कर दिया जसन वेब टोकन ही हटा दिया
तो अी एक काम करते हैं बैक करते हैं टोकन
को रहने देते
हैं एल्गोरिदम को नन कर देते हैं देन सेंड
करते हैं सो अगेन इनवैलिड टोकन ठीक है तो
इनवैलिड टोकन इसको भी रहने देते हैं इसको
भी रहने देते सब रहने देते हैं अब यहां पे
हम देखते हैं कि एक नए रैंडम टोकन से साइन
करके अगर यह कोई मिस कॉन्फिन है
जेडब्ल्यूडी न्यू सिमेट्री के चलते यहां
पर जनरेट करते हैं एक टोकन को यहां से हम
जनरेट करके यहां प ओके करके यहां पे सेव
कर देते हैं अब इस टोकन से हम साइन करके
देखते हैं कि अगर कोई किसी तरह का कुछ मिस
कॉन्फिन वगैरह पड़ा है तो साइन पर क्लिक
करेंगे
एंड यहां पे ओके करेंगे यहां पे एंड लेट्स
सी इफ वी कैन डू
समथिंग ठीक है तो यहां पे अब सेंड करके
देखते हैं इनवैलिड टोकन तो यहां पे ये
डिटेक्ट हो रहा है बेसिकली इट्स गेटिंग
डिटेक्टेड एंड इट्स नॉट वल्नरेबल इस तरीके
से बट आप और भी जो लोकेशंस है आप इसको
जैसे लॉगइन डिटेल्स पे आप आएंगे चेंज
पासवर्ड पे आएंगे आप चेंज पासवर्ड करके
देख सकती है ऐड ट्रेवलर पे जाएंगे ऐड
ट्रेवलर आप ऐड कीजिए यहां पे कुछ डिटेल्स
डालिए यहां पे को ट्रेवल पे जाइए लॉग इन
डिवाइसेज पे जाइए आप चेक आउट कीजिए कि कौन
से लॉग इन डिवाइस इसको एक्सप्लोर करके
देखिए राइट यहां पे फिर लॉग आउट पे जाइए
एंड यहां पे आप लॉग आउट कर सकते हैं एंड
आप इसको एक्सप्लोर कीजिए प्रॉक्सी पे चलिए
और देखिए कहां से कोई जेडब्ल्यू t निकल के
आ रही है किसी तरह का कोई जेडब्ल्यू टोकन
मिल रहा है उसमें कोई चेंज हम कर सकते हैं
किसी तरह का कुछ थ कर उसको आप ब्रूट फोर्स
करने की कोशिश कीजिए यहां पे है कट का
यूज़ कर रहे फिर आप अ जॉन द रीपर का यूज़
कर सकते हैं किसी भी तरह के पासवर्ट
हैकिंग टेक्निक का यूज़ कर सकते हैं जस्ट
ट्राई ठीक है तो ये एक अप्रोच है ये एक
मेथड है जो आप अभी सीख रहे हैं जो अभी
आपने जाना कि हमें जेडब्ल्यू टोकन फाइंड
करना हमें जो भी वेब एप्लीकेशन जो भी
हमारा टारगेट है उसको एक्सप्लोर करना है
आपको एटीटीपी हिस्ट्री ऑन कर देनी है
एक्सप्लोर करते रहिए जितनी फंक्शनैलिटी है
जो भी है सारी चीजें एक्सप्लोर कीजिए एंड
उसके बाद आप आप आके देखिए यहां पे हमारे
पास कोई ऐसी रिक्वेस्ट आई है जो
कि मैं आपको दिखा देता
हूं जो कि 200 स्टेटस कोड है पैरामीटर भी
है आपके अंदर में पैरामीटर है तो और भी
बेटर है एंड यहां पे जेडब्ल्यूडी टोकन
आपके पास अवेलेबल है फिर उसको आप रिपीटर
भेज के आप पहले तो जेडब्ल्यू को ब्रूट
फोर्स करके देखिए इफ गेटिंग ब्रूट फोर्स
या अलग-अलग तरह के जो जेडब्ल्यू के मिस
कॉन्फिन है उनको ट्राई आउट कीजिए अगर मिस
कॉन्फिन से निकलती है और वहां से आ रही है
तो वहां पे आप करके आप ट्राई कीजिए कि हां
कोई चेंजेज करके ला रहे हैं फिर आप जब आप
रिपीटर पे जाएंगे जब आप जेडब्ल्यू में
इसमें कोई चेंजेज करेंगे पलट के अंदर में
किसी तरह का कोई चेंज करना है वो चेंज
कीजिए एंड अगर ये आप चेंज पॉसिबल है चेंज
आप कर पा रहे हैं चेंज रिफ्लेक्ट कर जा
रहा है सामने एंड वो चीज एग्जीक्यूट हो जा
रही है तो फिर आप वहां पे उस टोकन को आप
रिपोर्ट कर सकते हैं वो आपका टोकन
कंप्रोमाइज हो जाता है एंड दैट कैन बी
रिपोर्टेड सो ये पूरा प्रोसेस है जो आपका
चलता है जेडब्ल्यू हंटिंग के लिए या टोकन
हंटिंग के लिए एंड आई होप आप सबको क्लियर
कम से कम हुआ होगा इस अप्रोच से अब लाइव
हंटिंग के दौरान रियल में टोकन को फाइंड
करना एंड एक टोकन को निकाल लेना दैट इज अ
वनबिल तो वो आप लाइव में जरूरी नहीं है कि
आपको मिलेगा ही मिलेगा बट या यू कैन फाइंड
अगर आप चाहे तो आप तो फाइंड कर ही सकते
हैं बिल्कुल फाइंड कर सकते हैं तो आप बस
थोड़ा टाइम दीजिएगा थोड़ा टाइम लगेगा एंड
जस्ट गिव इट अ ट्राई ठीक है बस
दैट्ची और इधर भी लाइव देख सकते हैं कोई
दिक्कत नहीं ठीक है सभी लोग जाते टाइम
लाइक ठोकते हुए जाइएगा ठीक
है नहीं नहीं उस अकीफ दिस इज नॉट
सेंसिटिव इ नॉट सेंसिटिव
राइट ओके तो आज के सेशन के लिए बस यहीं पे
हम एंड करते हैं आज का सेशन आई होप आप ने
लाइव हंटिंग एंड आपने जे
डब्ल्यूटीए ले लिया होगा जानकारी ले ली
होगी इसके लिए आप हंट करना शुरू कर दीजिए
जितना आप हं ज्यादा करेंगे जितनी आप
प्रैक्टिस करेंगे जितना टाइम देंगे एक
टारगेट पे उतना ही चांसेस आपका बढ़ जाएगा
याद रखिएगा जेडब्ल्यू टोकन कॉम्प्रोमाइज
करना इज नॉट इजी थिंग आज के टाइम में मिस
कन्फेशन मिलना भी नॉट इजी थिंग बट जब आप
ध्यान लगा के हंटिंग करेंगे तो वह भी आपको
मिल सकता है दैट आल्सो यू कैन फाइंड ठीक
है चलिए नो नो नो नो तो आई होप यू ऑल गॉट
एंड आप समझ गए होंगे आप सभी को समझ में आ
गया इतना तो समझ में आ गया आप सभी को
जल्दी से बता दीजिए एक बार सभी एवरीवन गट
दिस प्लीज लेट मी नो एवरीवन गट दिस जितने
लोग हैं उतने लोग बताइए काफी लोग तो जा
चुके हैं गायब हो चुके हैं बहुत लोग के
दिमाग के ऊपर से जा रहा होगा शायद
इसलिए
चलिए ऑलमोस्ट 144 लाइक्स आर देयर 150 पूरा
करते निकल जाइए एंड मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट
क्लास में ठीक है थैंक यू सो मच एवरी बडी
थैंक यू